a civil war has erupted but not in this
country in the fbi a whole bunch of fbi
agents apparently are furious they want
chris ray out they think he's biased
they're concerned that the agency has
been besmirched by this political bias
and you've also got this other story
about the staging of photographs trump's
piss because apparently the doj the fbi
took a bunch of top secret documents
spatted them all over the floor took a
picture of it and people are claiming
that's how trump had documents thrown
about his floor
they're now claiming that trump has
admitted to breaking the law with
classified documents
except he's the president
so he has unilateral declassification
powers it's the stupidest thing and
they're saying well trump doesn't
remember declassifying that that's
that's not how it works look
just read politifact you guys love pulit
effect right they say the president
doesn't need a process he can just be
like hey it's declassified otherwise how
would any of this make sense
so we'll talk about all that stuff we
got a bunch of other stories but before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member you want to
help support our work we're gonna have
that spicy members only show coming up
at 11pm but more importantly
please friends
help me lure
more people into my right wing world by
buying the song clicking the link in the
description below going to band camp and
searching for only ever wanted for those
that are staring at the screen right now
the daily beast published an article
where they said
tim poole is using the song to lure
people into his right wing world oh
heavens well if you'd like to help me
lure people into my into lure people
into my right wing world then uh the
link in the description below is is
right there and you can buy the song and
support our work thanks for the
commercial daily beast y'all you guys
are crazy i just want to say that the
daily beasts y'all are nuts they wrote i
can't believe they wrote about this but
i could not have asked for a better
commercial i think that the reality is
they're terrified
they're just they're they're terrified
and the claim that i am using rock music
to lure people into my right wing world
is laughable because what do you think
it's called when natalie portman does an
interview on a tv show she's doing and
then says oh and by the way defund the
police because of white privilege what
would you call that so spare me your
empty uh arguments
but i appreciate the the commercial
joining us also also smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends all that good
stuff joining us today to talk about a
bunch of issues is billboard chris
thank you so much for having me who are
you i'm a dad from vancouver british
columbia and i travel around north
america
hanging out on the street wearing signs
that say children cannot consent to
puberty blockers
or my definition of a dad which is a
human male who protects his kids from
gender ideology
i talk about the harm coming to kids we
have another big story the boston
children's hospital
apparently got a bomb threat but we may
have some uh insider sourcing it sounds
like this may be uh
a hoax and a hoax a triple hoax actually
i think and uh we'll we'll break that
down as to why i mean obviously there
was a fake bomb threat but there's a
bunch of other information as to how
this may be uh more political or
something strange but uh billboard chris
thanks for hanging out my pleasure we
also have libby emin she's back hey guys
glad to be here libby emmons editor at
the post millennial editor-in-chief
the best part about having libby on the
show is that the post-millennial then
embeds tons of tim cast irl all over
them oh my god we sure do yeah yeah
beth beth base is out there helping us
out tonight watching the show pulling up
shout out beth what's going on hi beth
uh hey everyone ian crossland here and
if you haven't seen the new cast castle
you should i was in it and it was great
uh it's on youtube there's a clip on
youtube but you really gotta go to
timcast.com and subscribe and then go to
cass castle on the left if you want the
full monty it's it's it is already up on
youtube there's a bit part of it so what
we're doing is once a week we put the
cameo bits up as as like gag reels sort
of like sketches
marjorie taylor green turns out she's a
pro-tier magic the gathering player mtg
plays mtg check it out still salty yeah
i am
i had no idea that margie taylor green
could play this really weird old nerdy
card game i'm also here pushing buttons
in the corner i'm excited to have chris
and libby let's get into it all right
here's the first story from the new york
post
fbi agents say director christopher wray
has got to go lost control of the agency
fbi director christopher reyes lost the
confidence of rank and file fbi agents
after a senior bureau official left
under a cloud of accusations that he
shielded hunter biden's laptop from a
criminal probe and some believe the top
g-man should step down a new report says
quote
i'm hearing from fbi personnel that they
feel like the director has lost control
of the bureau
kurt
how you pronounce it sued zach
a lawyer representing fbi whistleblowers
told the washington times in a report
published tuesday they're saying how
does this guy survive he's leaving he's
got to leave the fbi agents are telling
me they have lost confidence in rey all
ray does is go in and say we need more
training and we're doing stuff about it
or we will not tolerate his comments
come in the wake of tim tebow is that he
pronounces some people are saying it was
to beau is
is the top agent in charge of the fbi
field office in washington either
resigning or being forced out the door
amid claims he blocked investigations
into the first son's laptop so this is
this is this is big i mean i'm not
entirely sure anything actually will
happen here but this is what i've been
talking about for some time that the
culture war issues
exist in all fest of this country and
and the the federal institutions are not
exempt from people watching garbage
mainstream media and believing garbage
fake news i got i really like the
no-nonsense uh attitude of some of these
fbi agents and really like if any agency
on earth is going to have a no-nonsense
mindset it's the fbi or one of them and
they're saying they're calling out rey
for acting like when they're like what
are you going to do what do you do we're
going to look into it and make sure that
we get better so that we can hit like
this platitudes is what they're called
usually you'll see like kamal or someone
will do it and it just kind of
goes under the radar no one really knows
how to how to counter it or to rebuff it
or to criticize it but these guys aren't
taking it they know that that's a that's
a crap answer i don't know i kind of
feel like
a lot of these guys are crooked i think
it's obvious by what's going on with
trump it's obvious by what happened with
russiagate all of that was fake complete
hoax
now they're going after trump claiming
it classified documents and it's like yo
he was the president like he determines
if it's classified this is crazy and
there are people who are just they don't
know how to use google or even read
politifact who are like whoa look at the
picture of the top secret that proves it
they believe it and there are people at
the fbi who are counting on this and
they're crooked and i think what's
happening with christopher wray is
they're like hey our credibility's shot
right now so our ability to be corrupt
is hindered by this guy's bad job can we
pretend like we're having reform and get
rid of him and then keep going about
being corrupt they had a lot of
complaints too the employees who
you know said that rey should resign one
of the things they said was that there
had been fabrication of terrorism cases
to elevate performance statistics and i
think that's actually really quite an
important detail because the biden
administration has used domestic
terrorism um as a you know crisis that
they believe we're having you've had
merrick garland saying that domestic
terrorism is the biggest threat to the
u.s and if the fbi has been jacking up
those stats just to make themselves look
better you have the entire
federal government basing their
determinations on something that's uh
bogus a lot of people are pointing out
that the doj posted publicly photos of
top secret documents and it's like okay
if they're classified then they just
break the law good question interesting
yeah it's because it's all fake i mean
it's oh you made a good point about the
fbi
trumping up terrorism charges i.e this
gretchen whitmer case i think there were
10 fbi agents involved in the senate
yeah there were like more fbi agents
involved than actual guys i think that
these
it's just so funny there's a lot of
people in the agency that are like i
don't want my kid in getting thrust into
some stupid civil war that was brought
up by my ineptitude or my avoidance of
doing nothing as as some corruption was
going on because i wouldn't stand for my
boss trumping up terrorism charges no i
think that's a really bad situation
i mean it's just so clearly uh a problem
because we have merrick garland going on
tv saying that domestic terrorism is the
biggest threat facing the country he
said that a number of times
and you had biden saying that same thing
and if the fbi is faking it
then what are they pouring all this
money into what does the department of
justice doing you know they're
they're going after regular americans
that the fbi is claiming our terrorists
perhaps you know what are we what are we
doing like these whitmer guys were
uh hanging out around a campfire getting
high talking about
random garbage that they wanted to do
like you do when you hang around a
campfire and you're getting high right
like you say whatever well and then the
fbi jumps in and it's like oh we can
encourage these guys to go nuts they
bring in some hot chick who smokes weed
with them in hotel rooms you know and
you know you're going to do whatever the
hot chick who's smoking weed with you
says that is the rule i would do that
you mean
you're going to entertain it right
literally do it you're going to go in
the house then they had to like buy guns
for them and everything yeah yeah like
don't you want to go and do this like
sure whatever you say take your clothes
off and they're like we got him we got
him he said yes
that's why i'm you know i look at the
stuff and
i gotta wonder right these these guys
are gonna go to jail two guys
there was a mistrial then they had
another trial i'm seeing a lot of people
report like the judge wasn't allowing
certain testimony in and the whole thing
they say it was a sham the left is
screaming ah this proves it and i'm just
like you know i'm not entirely convinced
there will be a civil war
because we're watching for six seven
years now some of the most intense and
absolute corruption we've ever seen and
everyone's kind of just like huh
how about that kind of interesting but
but you know more importantly in 2018
democrats win
in 2020 they still held the house
despite victories from the right and
it's like
dude
when they raid the former president's
house i hope i think it was james
lindsay you mentioned this that some
woman was like that's gone too far for
me like raiding a president's house i
hope that is true and come november
people are like but then not only do you
have to hope you'll win you have to hope
that the people who actually get in do
something right and that's a that's a
that's questionable as well because the
establishment gop and the establishment
democrats are basically the same thing
you know they're
right they're trying to maintain their
power the the mar-a-lago raid though is
crazy like you guys i'm sure looked at
the affidavit the
heavily redacted affidavit uh
from what i could gather
the doj is mad that trump had documents
that he could have declassified he did
stored him properly he did declassify
right and they were stored like but
their big complaint is that they were
stored improperly this is but but so
right am i right about that i don't know
trump turned over boxes yeah to the
national archive upon request they then
said wow look at this classified stuff
he might have more
so they asked an fbi agent saying hey we
think trump has more documents and so
they said okay we'll get a search
warrant for them right but the idea that
these are you know classified documents
when trump tweeted a long time ago
before before leaving the white house
that he was declassifying all of these
reports that's correct they're just it's
just very clear on that it's another
hoax man and the reason why you know i'm
saying maybe there won't be a civil war
is because
the left keeps believing this stuff the
machine keeps on a churning and even if
the republicans get in
they just say you know well we can't we
can't push too hard we had a couple of
republicans in here who are like we
can't impeach joe biden you know despite
all of the evidence of the malfeasance
and business illicit dealings with his
son not even an investigation
so what i think is when i say no civil
war what i mean is revolution the left
is engaged in some kind of revolution
they're uh you've got the all the crazy
race ideology gender ideology stuff
you've got the uh you will own nothing
world economic forum stuff
and it seems like
that's the direction we're heading
since 9 11 the american people have gone
nuts and it's more than just the united
states but people have gone totally
twisted on each other they've been
looking at each other like that maybe
we're the threat well we made a huge
mistake in allowing the authorization of
the patriot act that was a huge issue
yeah and what's happening is and nobody
cared i remember being stunned at the
time that so few people cared it's crazy
it's it's insane and the world is
creating a new government there's a
world government being formed right now
if the americans refuse to stop fighting
and they keep arguing with each other
when they end up getting a seat at the
table one no one's gonna take them
seriously when they're forming their new
government and it's gonna get formed
without us
and two
uh they might not even have a they might
not even have a say in what happens they
can literally have their new government
this is like cloud schwab they want to
make it
any part of some world government where
people are you know leaders are not
elected yeah in the way that we elect
them i actually you know brexit gives me
hope because britain was just like we're
actually just still going to be britain
y'all like yeah that's a form of rural
government is decentralized autonomy
like we could bring american ideals and
constitutionalism to the globe if we're
a unified people
offering they don't want well yeah
that's why we would have to fight
pervert to argue at the table they would
want to pervert our system of government
look at what they're saying the problem
they say i don't want to i'm like why
would we want to be part of some garbage
world guys look at it
look at what the leaders are saying
is that if you want free speech we have
to regulate your speech right they're
telling you that we're fighting for
freedom and then simultaneously it is
1984 that's correct yeah i mean they're
the ones with this massive top-down
approach telling us how we have to live
how we have to you know deal with our
cars how we have to deal with our kids
how we have to deal with our families
and our homes all of this they're
telling us what to do telling us that
you know it's from the bottom up and the
middle out right doesn't biden say that
constantly and it's not it's just a
complete lie they want to control us
from birth to death and to go along with
what they want and i think that we just
i mean it's at the point where you just
have to say no to anything the federal
government offers but you need to re you
need to propose something different if
you just say no you'll slowly get
steamrolled well we had something we had
something great right we had
constitutional democracy and we're not
going to have that anymore like it's a
fight i mean i don't like the term fight
necessarily but it's a constant struggle
to maintain economically it is democracy
the the right constantly saying no wait
don't while the left keeps expanding
what they're doing well look at what's
happening in california now right like
with the
uh they're going to phase out
gasoline-powered cars and now they're
telling you you can't charge your ev
yeah i mean
that's that's not that i want to like
you will own nothing well
i want to people you own nothing you
will lack freedom of movement i want to
get into that but i want to jump to this
story because this one was uh talk about
rhetorical escalation yes karine
jean-pierre reiterates that tens of
millions of americans are an extreme
threat to our democracy and freedom
their only supposed crime they vote
republican again the white house thinks
republicans are terrorists she actually
said that maga republicans yeah uh
that's 74 million people who voted for
trump a lot of people are an extreme
threat to our democracy what do you
think she's saying to the to the country
and the world when she says something
like that i think i know exactly what
she's saying i was talking to libby
about this a little bit before we
started i think the supply wait what am
i trying to say here i think the demand
highly outstrips the supply of white
nationalist terrorism and they need
people to be prepared we were talking
about that right exactly yeah they need
people to be terrorists so that they can
create uh false terrorism charges they
can have the department of justice
investigate their political opponents
did you see the uh the vox article
several years ago it was like 100
million americans believe what white
nationalists believe or whatever and it
was like some nonsense that had nothing
to do with anything it was like they
agree with you know market capitalism
that's what the other people believe
nationalism yeah hitler also drank water
meritocracy matters you know yeah that's
white nationalists
yeah so he's working hard and showing up
on but this is remember that's all white
nationals apparently this is the white
house literally coming out and saying to
your face as someone who opposes the
democrats and the cult you are a threat
to their government
typically things like this don't end
well for countries when the official
administration is coming out and saying
half the people are a threat to us
that's correct and there's just one the
other thing too is you have a current
administration investigating the
previous administration right and you
also have current lawmakers who are
republican lawmakers saying that they
are going to invest if they
take the congress that they are going to
investigate the current administration
this is what goes on in you know
totally failed states this is what goes
on in countries that are falling apart
is you know look at sri lanka what's
happening here right look at it look at
what happened in canada right yeah look
what it was in sri lanka what did
trudeau do you see what trudeau just
said yes about the reason people are
angry as climate change yeah
climate change is one of the reason
there's so much anger today is that why
you're so angry chris
the 2s lgbt a
he forgot the i oh
and he only put one plus in there there
should be at least three pluses and then
there should be a wtf yeah honestly
that's fair but he always puts the 2s
first because he's all about virtue
signaling and the 2s stands for two
spirits right which is apparently it's
not true but it's apparently
indigenous cultures also used to believe
that there were more than two sexes and
you could be both sexes or none double
virtue signal yeah
oh wow yeah a double virtue signal yeah
powerful that's why it's first
but i mean this is a the claiming the
climate change is the problem they just
keep doing it and i'm just sitting here
thinking like do people really believe
this are they sitting there being like i
can't afford to eat climate change or
are they like i want the government to
you know to stop
banning fuel production and things like
that
the
average canadian
so here's what happens
if you don't put a stop to what's
happening in the u.s because i'm like
the canary in the coal mine we're
already way past where you guys are
things are terrible up there we have
three main media sources
all on the government payroll ctv cbc
and global news they would all be
bankrupt if not for government money wow
and they just push trudeau's agenda and
they say whatever he wants so the
average person has no idea the truth
about things because all they see is
this lamestream media all the time
but
my word we've got the same problems you
guys have the whole world does it's
inflation terrible economy
indoctrination not education
feels like a controlled slow motion
demolition
yeah these people believe that words are
violence
and they actually they believe that it's
actual violence and that's because
they've never experienced real hardship
like you saw the thing where ben shapiro
showed up at podcast movements yeah you
know and his presence was actual harm
that's right even though everyone was
stoked to see him there and they were
like can i take pictures with you
i put up a billboard about two years ago
in vancouver a real billboard that said
i heart jk rowling
a vancouver politician said it was hate
speech what and they took it down the
next day wow love is hate
love it had a heart on it
for the world's greatest children's
author
and no sign company in canada will deal
with me wow this is the state of things
so that's why i had signs made because i
became a billboard and i go out and have
conversations but
freedom of speech is under attack we're
lied to constantly and all the media do
is stoke division same thing down here
you know
i recall that a couple hundred years ago
we hear americans offered quebec an
opportunity to revolt against the crown
and they said no
do you guys know that yeah it would have
been the 14th colony but they were like
nah we're not interested and we're like
oh man we really need their support oh
well i guess not and then we almost took
you guys over do you remember that
i think that might be revisionist
history i think i think we burned down
your white house in your congress back
well britain did yeah it was before
canada existed right okay fair point we
uh we tried i think we did occupy
montreal or something like that 65
canada became a country 1867.
i think we occupied montreal during the
war of 1812 or something like that oh
nice montreal isn't it occupying it's
like but and it is awesome when you're
not getting attacked yeah yeah yeah yeah
but imagine this
what if we won
and we took montreal
y'all be better off what would would be
us yeah we'd be better off because they
have a really large antifa contingent so
if you want to take over them that's
fine yeah yeah you can have them like
take dc yeah but if we did that it would
be a bunch of maga they'd all be walking
around with american flags and i wonder
yeah i mean i don't think the french
canadians would be that maga though no
but who knows who knows man and montreal
is different within road not travel
within the province there's a lot of
english speakers it's very different
compared to the rest of the province i'm
just saying you know
canada sucks like it's a great place
with great food and great people but i
mean the government and what it's done
to the country has just made it an awful
place this is what happens if aoc was
your president
wow
this is exactly what happens justin
trudeau president zoolander is the aoc
equivalent
he talks like this it's also an example
it's also fake what happens if you let
your government be a puppet of a king
and just pretend like you're not a
puppet of a king like it's
it's british it's it's owned by the
freaking queen she decides who's in
charge there it's it's
that's disgusting i don't think that's
true of the provincial leaders and they
have a lot of the provincial leaders
have a lot of i'm pretty much i'm pretty
sure
the queen of england technically could
intervene but i don't know if it's
politically provincial
oh yeah and everything i don't know if
it's realistic though i don't understand
monarchy yeah it's complicated we have
this there's this person called the
governor general who's actually
appointed by the prime minister but is
the representative of the queen you see
there it is it's just a
it's just like a
what do you call it ceremonial sort of
thing but is it though well so here's
what can happen
because we don't have
we have we don't have a two-party system
like down here we have four or five
parties that get seats so justin trudeau
has a minority of the seats in
government so to pass any law he has to
get some other party to come along with
him so he ends up bribing some other
party by giving them what they want and
that's always an even further left party
but at any time he could be kicked out
if the parties just said no we're not
going to go along with you and then a
new election would get called and it's
the governor general who actually does
that so she does have some role but as
far as i can tell that's about it i
think we just look to canada
and if we do not win the culture war
that's what's in store for us so we're
lucky in that regard that we get to
watch it happen to you guys and then be
like hey we don't want that to happen
here so let's uh you know shore up our
defenses get out and vote get out and
vote in november to make sure there was
a time in american history where there
was a rebellion a violent rebellion
people were shot people it was called
shea's rebellion it was in seventeen oh
yeah
yeah that's right eight 1783 right
around right after the revolution and um
a bunch of farmers were being taxed with
for money they didn't have so they
rioted they went to the courthouses over
the course of like a week or multiple
days and weeks or whatever and uh
violently
surrounded them the judges were like i'm
out of here i'm not adjudicating we're
not going to steal their land the
governor cracked down hard like he
wanted people's executed he wanted
people arrested
and it was he was calling people i don't
know if he was using the word terrorist
but calling you know the whole
insurgency thing we got to go after
people the farmers are our enemies and
they were like if you start killing
americans because they are revolting
because they can't pay their taxes
that's a bad road to go down it's a very
bad road to go down eventually john
hancock came back in and won the
governor's ship and pardoned everybody
except for two guys who were looters and
they got executed but it was the pardon
that it was like the road to banana
republicanism we saw it we saw it where
it was just just another cycle of the
week becoming strong executing the week
and trying to hold strength and that and
they they now we have a situation where
we have a president who told us that
taxes were not going to be raised
on people making under four hundred
thousand dollars it's very that's a
trick like beaudoing they are they are
being raised and they have employed all
of these irs agents and he's it's not
just about raising taxes that's the
trick the trick is they say we're not
going to raise your taxes no we are
going to just bill you on your existing
taxes and claim you owe us yeah
yeah but they're also i mean they're
going after the middle class again yeah
of course yeah the villainization of an
entire group of people like what they
said about mega republicans is like this
boat what beaudoin did in massachusetts
and the mega republicans are like
these are middle class small business
owners you know nail shop owners out in
the middle of indiana or wherever and
they're gonna end up paying a whole
bunch more get more pissed and then be
called terrorists very much like history
might repeat itself here because in
massachusetts for shea's rebellion the
governor was out of his it was hancock
was governor and saw the rebellion on
the horizon i was like i'm i'm resigning
i can't do this anymore so he left then
this new governor came in became this
tyrant
kind of like what biden's doing claiming
people are terrorists i don't like it
and then eventually hancock was like
okay i can't not do anything he's he ran
again got back into the governorship and
pardoned people now if we have a
president it runs again and then comes
back into the presidency and pardons
people
wouldn't that be an interesting well you
know a revolution of the past you know
right that was funny that if donald
trump is indicted
and goes to prison or is in jail or
whatever and then
is still running for president and wins
he can pardon himself
oh is that right can you probably
yourself i i think it's debatable yeah i
remember there was a lot of talk about
this a few years ago it would get
challenged but apparently he could i
think i mean what do you do when someone
in prison is elected president
[Laughter]
just
safe there you know what i mean i guess
sort of safe depending on what kind of
prison he's in
when i guess the charges would be things
like obstruction of justice mishandling
of documents that are in your possession
that you actually own that's what
they're trying to do can you run for
president if you're in prison no you
can't
hold on they're going they're going
after this records law that says if you
obfuscate manipulate or destroy records
you can't run for office that's what
they're trying to do they just really
don't want them to run again everything
that they've been doing is about that's
the same thing with shay's rebellion
they wanted to strip these people of all
their uh voter rights they wanted to
strip people of their land they took
they seized people's property like
they're trying to make them non-citizens
they were trying to make them
non-citizens and eventually it was just
like you can't do that you can't you
can't make a country if you're making
people non-citizens that's correct yeah
um i want to jump to this story here
from the post-millennial oh my
occupied democrats demands boycott of
spotify after joe rogan says vote
republican
talk about a bunch of whiny little
babies
joe rogan has opinion quick boycott the
entire largest music platform in the
world luck with that paul's manual says
during a recent episode of his podcast
rogan highlighted the failures the
democratic party's handling of the covet
pandemic suggesting that people should
vote republican instead it drew ire from
many on the left obviously who went so
so far as to call on their followers to
boycott the popular music and podcast
podcasting platform
spotify i mean occupy democrats they
post a bunch of fake news anyway they're
kind of nuts
they say if you support a boycott of
spotify until they drop joe rogan's
podcast after he just ignorantly urged
americans to vote republican as payback
for businesses closing down due to the
pandemic dangerous rhetoric as the gop
embraces full fascism
please retweet and follow us well you
know donald uh it was joe biden who said
semi-fascism they had to one-up him i
don't think they know what the word
means
well i don't think they care what the
word means yeah everything's upside down
yeah everything is something i mean they
they you look look look but i produced
this is going to go as well as neil
young's boycott of spotify sure sure i
propose this how about someone out there
makes a browser extension and we select
a bunch of keywords like far right
fascist semi-fascist whatever and we
replace it with bad thing
that's it
so like bad thing person and it'll be
like you know business is closing down
due to bad thing or you know uh gop
embraces embraces bad thing
just that that's all it means it doesn't
mean anything other than bad thing so we
get a browser extension it just changes
these phrases into the phrase bad thing
there we go that'd be the name of the
extension bad thing i like that actually
i would translate the left
that's right that's kind of that's
really smart i like it another one of
your good ideas inaccuracy with occupy
democrats here rogan is not ignorant no
he's done enough research over the last
10 years i can i can safely say from a
distance the guy not a genius lol
actually i think you are a genius joe
but yeah
i think he is honestly he's a brilliant
guy yeah um not ignorant he knows what
he's talking about this is not what it
is light decision that he's making or
talking about joe is not a genius yeah
but he's been he's been taken he's been
smoking dmt and we've been long enough
and psychedelics and nad and so it's
like his mind has just ascended to a new
level
so in the fourth dimensional state he's
kind of just a regular intelligence but
to all of us lowly three-dimensional
beings he's way out there also if you
watch that segment he's saying vote
republican almost like to bring balance
back to this thing and it was the
democrats that shut down businesses they
shut down our schools they shut down our
churches they left
you know the cathedrals to sin open they
left open the liquor stores they left
open the casinos
um
but they closed down the things that
yeah they closed down the things that
give us community that help us you know
learn things they close down libraries
they close down all this stuff and now
we're supposed to just be like oh that
was okay you did that for really good
reasons no they were garbage reasons we
all know they're garbage reasons you
have everybody walking it back
you know i mean you even had kathy hokel
stupid governor of new york saying that
it was a mistake to close schools but so
it was obvious at the time and it's
obvious now they're saying it now
because an election's coming
and they're scared what i don't like
about what
joe what joe said in this article but a
lot of people are saying vote republican
what i don't like about that is the
vague bland vote r on a ticket
regardless of who it is because idiot
random dude that has bad intentions can
join the republican party and then get
that vote
you should vote for the good candidate
the right candidate it doesn't matter
what party they're the thing a trans
satanist anarchist
won the nomination for i think sheriff
or whatever by running brands satanists
who's up in new hampshire yeah that
sounds like i'm sure to make a point to
make a point being like you would just
vote for whatever's got an r on it
that's your fault people were pissed
they were like wait this person won like
you voted for him that's like there was
a you guys probably don't remember this
but there was an episode of will and
grace where they were trying to figure
out who to vote for and grace was
hosting a fundraiser for the jewish
candidate and will was hosting a
fundraiser for the gay candidate they
ended up getting into a huge fight and
whatever and then at the end what's his
name the other guy comes in
jack the best character on the show he
comes in he sees that they're arguing
and he's like why didn't you just vote
for the black guy and they're like
there's a black guy running and they
both run out to vote for the black guy
when was this this was whenever will and
grace was on what was that the 90s it
was hysterical it was like so perfect
just bang on back when identity politics
was fun was amusing back in the 90s
because when they're also
before comedy was terrorism
yeah really yeah that's 9 11 all over
again i i keep talking about pardons on
this show from time to time but it's
like since 9 11 people went psychotic
and we got to like just
move on man because we are forming a
world government right now and if we
don't move on they're moving all without
us well let me let me look e
to to put myself into the fray let me
just point out like why this stuff
persists
the daily beast read this article i
mentioned earlier where they claim that
i'm i'm trying to lure people into my
right wing world with rock music
this is the insanity that they're
telling people and i i i don't want to
you know forgive the sort of
self-promotive you know promotion i
guess that comes out of this but my
point is
there are people who read the daily
beast as a mainstream corporate
publication and this is the world they
live in
it is
literally insane they are in a psychotic
paranoid delusional
they believe this stuff now i think the
daily beast is writing this because it's
you basically you could create a a daily
beast article generator and click a
button and have it spit out a name in
some words jackpot far right you know uh
hoax or whatever and it'll just randomly
throw in random random person's name
random identifier random thing they did
and that's the daily beast but when
there are people who believe this
insanity what happens to their brains i
had one guy
said he was mad at me for breaking
consensus reality bro you don't live in
consensus reality
you live in the crackpot reality of
weird algorithmically driven garbage
articles that make no sense
but this is what makes people lose their
minds and the reason why they hate joe
rogan so much is that joe rogan appeals
to regular people
i think he may be
a vaccine as it were socially to stop
people from being
of contracting the mind tip
so to speak you know you've mentioned
911 a couple times i think that's also
coincident with when the internet really
took off which has enabled division to
be stoked but also what's going on today
i go to universities and i hang out
sometimes on campus i've been to many
ivy league universities and i talk to
these students wearing my signs
they are teaching these kids now they're
training this generation
that it's not okay to have a different
opinion you can't just be okay with it
you have to be actively engaged in
trying to cancel the other opinion
anti-racism isn't just about
being against racism it's about actively
trying to cancel people who you disagree
with
and they're creating these social
justice warriors this whole young
generation can't even have a
conversation
because words are violence to them and
it was well looked at in 2012 i think
it's tick tock i think that bite dance
and the ccp are really intentionally
driving this algorithm in the united
states trying to get people to hate each
other
well i think tick-tock honestly i never
used to write i never used tik-tok once
twitter is doing that twitter is doing
that but what tick-tock is doing is
making sure that anyone who opposes the
cult can't have a platform tons of
people on the right have been banned for
literally no reason i mean tim cast irl
is banned from tick tock we don't know
why yeah and they're from what i've been
told they're not it's a different
algorithm that tick-tock uses in the
united states than what it uses in china
they push science and technology at the
top in china whereas they push gender
ideology to the top in the u.s yep
that's i mean that's not non-intention
that's definitely someone chose to do
that but this stuff was happening before
tick-tock or any of these other things
you know there was this push to
not educate scholars but to
turn out activists so it's a completely
different
way of
engaging in instruction right it used
like it used to be the way that you
engage at in a university is that you're
having a discussion you've all read the
material and any idea is open for
discussion it doesn't matter how crazy
it is it doesn't matter if you agree
with the idea or not come up with an
idea throw it out there let's talk about
the idea and now it has so much more to
do with you know forming a belief system
that then you can go
and act as an activist out in the world
and get people to
um sign on to your belief system that's
not what it used to be it i mean the
idea that a scholar is someone who has
to believe a certain set of things and
never question them that's not
scholarship
that's that's cultish behavior speaking
of activists i was in san francisco two
months ago down by the pier with my
signs with a woman who came out with me
and it was a weekday schools were in
session
there were about 80 elementary school
kids 10 and 11 years old
down there protesting
in favor of abortion and trans rights
10 and 11 year olds out on a school
field trip protesting on a school field
trip
the school had them go out and do it
three different classes and they were
not they were not just protesting right
they were protesting for the eradication
of of babies
and for the sterilization of teenagers i
mean look as long as
talk about anti-humanism if the
pro-america side if the freedom
libertarian side conservative side wins
on school choice then give it 20 to 40
years and the problem corrects itself
i think a lot of it you mentioned
earlier the internet how it kind of
coincided with 911 and i i think what's
internet videos been weaponized i
thought for sure back in 2006 like
internet video is the future i was right
it's just been weaponized as part of it
and
uh the power like for instance i made a
video when barack obama was running for
president 2007 i made a video and said
barack you're going to win you're going
to serve two terms i was just like let's
manifest let's create this and give it
confidence so you're responsible for all
those kids
steve grove at youtube one of the
administrators featured the the article
so basically together we create a
political prop again i didn't think of
it at the time i was just like i want
obama to win it got 50 000 views i don't
know how many people voted for obama as
a result but talk about mass formation
like the power of internet video that an
individual can inspire the minds of
almost the entire world is
it's disconcerting let me let me jump to
this story we got from the post
millennial
breaking connection that's right
connecticut assistant principal placed
on leave after project veritas expose
this is crazy this veritas expose from
the other day oh this is wild this is
totally wild this dude's basically
bragging about how he's breaking the law
to uh like violating non-discrimination
laws saying he won't hire conservatives
catholics or people over 30. people over
30 right all of this is just meanwhile
look at this guy like why does he have a
job
that's a good question
and he's like well these people they're
brainwashed and i'm like dude
when you refuse to expose people to
other ideas it's you that's the cult you
not the other people who are actually
okay with different ideas competing with
each other
but this guy's now placed on leave the
crazy thing is there's a video i think
you guys i don't know if you guys have
it where james o'keefe oh yeah we have
that in a different story yeah they ran
like multiple stories on this james
confronts the guy at a bar restaurant
and they threatened they called the cops
and the cops threatened to arrest him
yeah yeah this is crazy but this is it
this is one school it's one school in
connecticut good job project super fancy
part of connecticut i mean but just just
you need to understand that this is an
example of what parents need to be
watching out for
he's basically saying he won't hire
someone who doesn't agree with trans
ideology he wants teachers to come in
and tell the kids whatever the kids want
to hear and what he wants them to say
and he's like i'm pretty good at making
sure we don't hire any catholics or
conservatives you can't ask him but you
can ask other things and then i just
call him and say you know we've moved on
to another
candidate this is what they're doing at
your schools man if you don't if you
don't
keep an eye on what's going on you're
going to wake up one day and be like why
did my kid shave shave their head and
now they hate me
well i mean your kid can shave your head
and hate you without joining a
cult can't they yeah but what i mean is
i mean
that's like teenagers we've talked about
this a lot the the cult indoctrination
at these schools especially at colleges
and we've had tons of people come on
this show and like while we're getting
ready for the show they're like yeah my
kid's about to go to college and i was
like do you read your own tweets yeah
why are you doing that they just because
it's just no like this is why i'm like i
don't know maybe there won't be a civil
war because the right will just sit
there and shake their fist while the
left stage is a revolution because even
knowing the schools are doing this they
keep sending their kids to these schools
it's like okay i guess sure fine
whatever
well it is hard i mean as a parent it's
hard to try and like
figure out if there's a path that you
can take
you know i talk to my kid all the time
about all of these things homeschooling
well micro schooling private schools you
got to do all of these things you got to
figure it out i'm just going to never
said it i'm just saying it is hard to
figure out a choice it's a full-time job
to figure out how to educate your kid
yeah no one ever said having kids was
easy yeah i didn't say it was easy my
son actually said like he wants to go to
college and i'm like you could also just
buy a truck i got an idea though
hear me out
i i hear what you're saying about it
being a full-time job what if we created
some kind of like cultural institution
where there was a parent who would
work and make money and acquire
resources while the other parent
principally helped raise those kids and
then through that partnership you'd have
like a healthy family to raise these
kids and instill values in them you know
what i mean like what could we call
something like that i don't know maybe
like a fa family
family sounds like evil white supremacy
colonialism to me
or something geez
the other thing too is i was recently
listening to or something i was
and somehow i was absorbing information
about
what who knows i don't know how about
divorce about like the history of
divorce in the u.s and i have come to
the conclusion that no fault divorce was
a total mistake this should never have
been absolutely out loud at all
right yeah terrible i love this one we
never should have done this media
matters i think it was media matters one
of these lefty outlets wrote like tim
cast irl the right wing is now coming
for no fault divorce and i'm like okay
yeah like what how do you protect
against no fault divorce as a guy as a
woman too i guess but like i have like
you know i
i'm in my 40s i know lots of women who
are no longer married uh there's crazy
stories you know a guy wakes up one day
and he's like i don't want to be married
to anymore and then he takes the house
and tries to take the kids and you're
like what what did i do what happened
and the inverse yeah and the women doing
the same thing guy comes home one day
the locks were changed and she's like
here's the papers this is just crazy
yeah you signed three knobs i've heard
but then i've been told like they're not
enough like even if you have a prenup
that says half of it if you have to if
you have to sign a prenup like don't
marry that person correct i feel like
prenup should be embedded in the
marriage contract so you don't have to
feel bad about it but that's crazy too
like then why get me like what's the
point of getting married yeah you're
more money you used to not be able to
get divorced you you'd go and you'd be
like i'd like to get a divorce and then
the judge would be like no denied bank i
think they'll get counseling the idea of
getting married is i'll bring my 10
million you bring your 600 000 and then
with our 10.6 million we make 100
million more and we split that but you
don't get my original 10 million i love
that like this 10 million brought to the
marriage in the first place i just
remembered what it was that i was
listening to it was the criminal podcast
about this woman who was trying to get
divorced from her husband after he had
uh been convicted of murder and she had
to go to south because she had to go to
south it was like i don't know some time
before now she had to go to south shore
right you know what i'm saying like but
then he was exonerated is what happened
and she could so she could have
potentially gotten the divorce because
he was in prison but then he was
exonerated his dad got him off on like
all these reasons uh and so she had to
go to south dakota and live there for
like a year in order to qualify to get
divorced because it was legal there and
then south dakota changed their law and
other people started having no fault of
force and whatever but yeah criminal
podcast i like that did you catch what i
was saying about the the prenup embedded
prenup that how why i think it makes
sense
yeah because then you don't have to
worry about it when you get divorced
like marriage is a business contract and
you bring in your initial investment and
they bring their initial investment i
don't see why they should have access to
your initial investment before you know
them i kind of feel like considering
marriage as a as a business contract
defeats the entire point of marriage i
that's not how i would ever view
marriage as a business arrangement it's
just financial then why do it just so
you don't have to get taxed when you
give your wife a hundred thousand
dollars a year i hate this idea of
marriage
i i don't that's all that's that's not
what marriage is it's just like i can
give you more than fourteen thousand
dollars a year
you would just hurt each other tax wise
well what you would do is you do it
because you want to make more money
together no that's the idea we're going
to come back
you don't understand a million dollars
to start with like you should probably
be getting married in your early 20s you
know you're hurting the taxes of the
other person if you marry them if you
have that much money
unless you're if you're stagnant if
you're stagnant if i come out no no no
no no no no when someone when someone's
making you know 250k and they marry
someone who's making 100 million or
making 25 million per year and now it's
a joint filing you basically have just
jumped straight up you have there's no
benefit received to the person who's
making less money they just get they
just get taxed more that doesn't make
sense they're also making 12.5 million a
year because they're married to someone
that's making 25. yeah but here's the
other piece of that is like if you're
both these wealthy millionaires like
how do you even have time to find
someone to fall in love with like that
really is a business contract like
working to make a lot of money is
um maybe i'm just doing it wrong i
should clarify too because i think it's
a thing the highest bracket what's the
highest bracket it's 250 right 250 and
up i have no idea so so it's actually
like if someone's making 50k and they
marry someone who's making 500 it's bad
tax-wise it's like i mean i would not uh
encourage getting married and not trying
to make more money i think the purpose
is you're going to make at least 10
times what you're making a loan if
you're married
i don't think it's bad tax wise
and i say this as a former financial
advisor because the 500 person can come
down to a lower tax bracket right
because well it would basically put a
a half of their money they would get
another 125k towards
deductible or whatever or no no that's
not how it works it's um
it's
yes you're right right right like what
i'm trying to say is
the overall tax bracket might come down
but what i'm trying to say is if you're
acting as an individual who wants a
prenup it is bad for you to enter this
arrangement because it benefits the
person who has more money and depending
on how much money they have it may not
actually be a benefit at all for anybody
so what i'm trying to get at is the
system itself is being set up in such a
way that it really really disincentifies
marriage disincentivizes marriage like
you can lose it's true on the poor side
too
i mean just across the board the whole
system is completely screwed up mm-hmm
but like if you're if you're poor
bring back the dowry that's what we need
right
you know
i have linens from my
great-grandmother's truso oh yeah that
she embroidered and brought with her
into her marriage i've been tossing
around getting married it's because i'm
dating this girl and i'm like i i want
to give her money every year but i don't
want to get taxed on it so like what's
the only way to do that is to have a
joint bank account it's basically you we
can share funds but i'm like it seems so
cold and calculated it sure does maybe
that's the way you're supposed to treat
marriage because it's all numbers it's
not like a love doesn't make love like
that's up to me i got to do that in my
own soul
i think the one of the big problems we
have is that um regardless of whether
they're conservative actually no no i i
would i would say this um principally of
conservatives
they are they are raising their children
extremely poorly now granted they're
doing better than than liberals for sure
what i mean though is
how is it
that there are conservative families
that are shocked to find their kids have
become
you know purple hair shaved head
you know
left extremists who hate their parents
guts
that's bad parenting that's it i don't i
mean maybe it's bad parenting it is you
you kicked your kids off
and then we're like what happened to my
kids maybe you should have paid
attention to what was going on with
their lives i think for a lot of parents
today when they think of school we think
of our own experiences in school
and a lot of them just have no idea how
much things have changed these aren't
education centers
they're indoctrination centers and
people are getting blindsided it's not
even it's it's it's also there's there's
more to it we had um you know our friend
richie mcginnis's mom was on and she's
an old school feminist and we tried
explaining to her that feminists today
are pro-war she was shocked said no
they're not yeah they are they all have
years like martina navratilova has
ukraine flag in her yeah they want to
pump money into the war machine correct
they want raytheon to see those record
profits and they're supposed to sell a
bunch of weapons to taiwan too like
exact billion dollars yeah
a billion dollar grant or whatever for
weapons but these older people don't pay
attention
they they've resigned from mo from
modern political and social life and now
the world's being burned down and
they're sitting back voting for it going
oh you're crazy it's not happening so
there are people who are like tim don't
rag on boomers
my friends i'm not ragging on you who is
intelligent smart who reads the news
fact checks and is questioning what's
going on and is watching the show and
it's watching the show i'm talking about
how we've had people on the show i'm
talking about
the the the large portion of boomers who
are voting democrat thinking they're
voting for like a hard work union guy
and they're actually voting for child
sex changes and they won't read a single
article online to save their own
children's lives it's not just boomers
it's it's literally anybody but you know
i think the issue is when it comes to
the older generation not just boomers
but anybody they consume television
media that's where they get their news
we are online so we're exposed to
counter information
they're not so they sit there in their
in their lounge chairs watching cnn
going wow can't believe that's true
again and no matter how many times
there's a hoax no matter how many times
there's a new jesse smallett they
believe it
at a certain point you got to be like
okay this thing's just full yeah there's
a there is a sense of erosion that is in
interplayed as well like it's not people
are not impervious to realizing what's
going on eventually sometimes enough you
know enough information appears in their
face they see enough
uh top genderqueer books or books about
this and that and seeing a 12 year old
with the masted double mastectomy and
they're like sometimes like an erosion
can happen slowly over time sometimes
all of a sudden a big piece of rock just
falls off and you're like whoa what am i
looking at the trick now is
are you familiar with black propaganda
the concept yeah so
this is what the left does
right
lying cheating stealing and the right
doesn't do these things they they they
try and take this straightforward
approach of here's what has to be done
and here's the harsh reality you go to
someone and say you're gonna have to
work hard to make a better future they
go
hard work then the democrats come along
and say you know those loans you took
out we're gonna make other people pay
for them and they're like sounds good to
me freebie right what they even say is
that no one's gonna have to pay for them
they lie about that too oh yeah yeah i'm
imagining what would happen
if you went door-to-door
knocking on doors in a swing district
and said that you were a democrat
you know voter
and you showed them the book genderqueer
and you said here's a book here's what's
in schools
do you think like how would people
respond to that
i think that i think that there's two
ways that they'll respond to it right i
mean some people would look at it and
they would say oh that's shocking i'm
going to start looking into this because
that's crazy and other people would just
say no they would do that thing where
they just don't even believe their eyes
but that's why i'm saying you don't make
any arguments you don't tell them like
if someone just literally handed them a
book and said like i want to just like
you buy you the problem is you buy the
book and you're helping the person who's
making the book but i'm just wondering
like what would happen if you were you
know in a neighborhood handing out these
books like what would what would they be
saying about it the far left likes it
but the problem with democrats these
days and the democratic party is they're
essentially being held hostage by the
far left wing of their party
because if they object to any of this
there's
they are called a bigot and to be called
a bigot as a democrat is like instant
death it's like none of them will stand
up to them
yeah blasphemer
no not me heretics so they don't all
agree copy of that book i bought a copy
of genderqueer because we were writing
about it a lot and i was like i should
just take a look at this book
um and the things that i found
horrifying about it had a lot less to do
with the graphic imagery and more to do
with the trajectory of the story by the
end of the book this main character who
now is non-binary is planning with a
euphoric sensibility how to come out to
their students because also
the character is a teacher now you see
like that's the weirdest thing to me
that
there are teachers who are like i want
to make sure all of these children know
who i like to bang right why would you
want that no we don't even we we we
would never even say our teacher's first
name like if you're not
excuse me oh you did at quick yeah so i
went to several different kinds of
schools i went to public school for
er through eighth grade and then i went
to catholic school for two years
and then i went to uh quaker school for
two years
what was that like quaker school
was great it was academically rigorous i
had teachers who
were old school professor style teachers
where
any idea that you wanted to talk about
was on the table i was having trouble in
my my english class with uh peter ranka
and we called him peter but um
did we call him peter i don't remember
anyways i think i called him mr rinka
because i came from catholic school and
i was used to calling people's sister so
it was anyways who cares the uh my point
is i was having trouble in english class
and so i talked to mr anko about it and
he said um
well what do you want to read and i said
i'd like to read
this book the castle by kafka and he was
like great read that
and we'll make time we'll talk about it
after school
and that's what we did
and it was great
and my philosophy classes were
interesting and i took you know
independent studies and writing plays i
mean it was ludicrous if everyone could
go to the school i went to the way it
was in the mid-90s
if everyone could go to that school
i wouldn't we wouldn't have these kinds
of problems to be honest i want to jump
to the story from the post-millennial oh
it's us again
bomb threat at boston children's
hospital ruled false police report no
suspicious items were observed or
located an incident report from the
boston police department specifies i
also want to say that my initial
assessment here was that it was a hoax
and a hoax but now it appears it's a
hoax hoax at a hoax
so i'll explain and then i'll throw it
to billboard chris but the first story
is clearly the bomb threat itself was
was clearly fake
but also the police did not even show up
until an hour and 20 minutes after the
call came in and they did not clear the
the the area until an hour or about an
hour later so i'm like okay the police
weren't even taking it seriously it was
around eight o'clock that the call came
in 20 where the police actually showed
up and then 10 o'clock when they
actually cleared the the space out so
you have the hoax of the call itself
you have the hoax of the media narrative
that everything got shut down and now
what's the latest so yeah there's a
couple employees there that send me the
emails they're getting so i get those
but then this employee told me
the weird thing is that they never sent
out an initial lockdown email only the
all clear one no added security this
morning either and this whole time the
last two weeks there's been no added
security no one in the hospital has been
getting any threats that this employee
knows of most people didn't even know
that i had tweeted out all these videos
originally they're just playing victim
trying to shift the narrative away from
their own words that everyone heard in
the videos that i tweeted out and
they're trying to make themselves into a
victim
but
there's really not that much going on
there what are their own fake news you
tweeted is that stuff
on youtube yeah it's all these so they
were on youtube these videos were on
youtube they had all these they took
them down yeah they had all these videos
on their youtube channel and
i was alerted to one of it one of them
so i tweeted it out it was about gender
affirming hysterectomies
how they will cut out the uterus of a
girl or young woman to affirm her gender
and it started to take off
post-millennial wrote about it
and
i thought i better record this because
it's getting some steam going here
and of course they deleted the video
so then i tweeted out my recorded
version of it i sent it to libsytic talk
i sent it to matt walsh they retweeted
it for me it went viral
and in the meantime i recorded about 40
other videos from their youtube site
that they have also deleted all of those
now are they still doing gender
affirming hysterectomies at the hospital
yeah and they even they even changed
their website they had a page talking
about how they do phalloplasties
on 17 year olds or sorry vaginoplasties
so this is yeah it was the vaginoplasty
yeah 17 year olds yeah this is where
they create a neo vagina for young men
or boys they castrate them and then
invert the penis
it gets gruesome guys but anyway they
changed their website it used to it used
to say 17 year olds now it says 18 year
olds they also claim that they follow
the wpath standards of care so wpath is
the world professional association for
transgender health they write the
standards of care that these gender
clinics can follow if they feel like it
but wpath is lowering the age for all of
these surgeries right now and their new
standards of care coming out next week
and in there they recommend womb removal
and testicle removal for 17 year olds
breast removal for 15 year olds
but a lot of these clinics are going
even younger than that i have kellen
lackhart on video from kaiser permanente
in oakland california admitting that
they cut off the breasts of a 12 year
old girl and they're castrating 16 year
old boys
we have lots of stories like this these
places are out of control there's no
regulation but humans love boobs that's
the crazy thing right that it it but
it's true what what does this look libby
well
but i mean like but these gender clinics
treat them as expendable like if someone
wanted to cut off their foot we wouldn't
cut off their foot what what i mean is
um
like there was the anyway i i may be
wrong but i'm pretty sure that humans
are the only mammalian species with
permanently swollen breasts i believe so
i believe that's true uh so most most
mammals only start producing and you
know their breasts only in gorge when
they're child rearing but humans are
different that's what i mean like humans
love boobs
and so it's it's this interesting thing
just to see that they're telling
children that these are bad things that
you should get rid of and they're
performing mastectomies on minor girls
yeah we've got johanna olsen kennedy
who's one of the top specialists in the
world who runs the gender gender clinic
at children's hospital los angeles she's
on video talking about a 13 year old
girl who got her breasts cut off and she
says what's the big deal
if they want to get breasts when they're
older they can just go buy them
you also have what do they think breasts
are right you also have doctors on tick
tock saying that they're going to eat
the teats and it's
that's what they say
they're like i'm going to eat teats
tomorrow it's very exciting and they get
all into it
olsen kennedy was also i think the
doctor um a doctor who was
treating
the child of an abc executive who was at
disney who was then advocating against
the parental rights and education bill
she also get this guys
she applied for a grant and was given a
grant it went to four hospitals
the nih national institute of health
gave 5.7 million dollars to four
different children's hospitals
as part of the grant they reduced the
age that these kids could receive the
opposite sex hormones
so this is girls getting testosterone or
boys getting estrogen well
they reduced the age as part of this
grant from 13 years of age to 8 years
old but but i also want to make sure
we're clarifying here they're not
actually giving kids testosterone or
estrogen they're giving them pseudo
right it's a it's a it's a faux it's not
actual human hormones well yeah
synthetic testosterone right right i
don't know how they produce it but yeah
but but so this is an important factor
because um for a long time i thought
they were giving legitimate human
hormones to children
they're not it's synthetic or it comes
from animals or things like that there
have been uh older trans people who have
advocated for like like horse estrogen
or something like that i've seen posted
on forums
so what i end up reading is that some of
these kids end up with very serious
ailments based on the hormones they're
getting because they're not quite the
same
i think one one example
of uh some because i'm not a bio a
biologist or a chemist or anything like
that but uh people talk about soy and
how soy feminizes people but i believe
soy is phytoestrogen which is it's a
different form it's like less potent or
something like that that i'm not i'm not
saying necessarily what that means other
than there are different kinds of
estrogen that affect the body in similar
ways but they are different
okay yeah and plus it doesn't belong in
their body they have a small amount of
testosterone girls do naturally but
they're getting dosages that are 20
times what they're supposed to have but
what i mean is if you give a human being
if a human being's body produces human
testosterone then the body reacts to it
but i'd imagine if you give a human
being horse testosterone or some other
synthetic it's going to react
differently than it would to actual
testosterone right but perhaps similarly
and we don't know because this whole
thing is a giant experiment right it's
never been done in the history of the
world
whether you believe in god or you
believe in evolution well obviously if
you believe in god you're saying god
made us wrong
by doing this to kids and if you believe
in evolution as i do well we've evolved
over about a billion years humans have
been on this planet only for maybe 300
000 years
but are we to believe now that for the
first time in human history in this
little 10-year window
that a pharmaceutical company is here to
help our children be who they really are
you don't trust pharmaceutical companies
evolution got it all wrong
you know i love this notion that the
left used to like 10 years ago they were
like these big pharma is bad and now
they're like big farmers good my friend
well it's all part of a piece too
because you have on the uh
at boston children's one of the
founders of the gender clinic there was
pioneering the use of puberty blockers
and younger kids
and that was something
i think that was started in like 2013 or
something like that boston children's as
part of their promotional
materials was showing profiles of kids
who
came to the clinic specifically for
uh
being young and being cared for in this
way at that clinic and they talk about
how they have to go into the hospital a
lot and they talk about this as a
positive thing you know they know right
why who i am and why i'm there they have
to get bone density scans they have to
get brain scans and all of this stuff
puberty blockers
yeah
there's a lot of concerns also the
makers of these drugs don't recommend
that you be on them for more than like
three or four months and kids are going
on them for years at a time and then
being ushered onto cross-sex hormones so
that's an issue as well and the way that
the the trans kids are promoted i think
is also really
a dangerous thing because they look so
happy and smiling and it's like yeah you
look great for these photo ops you know
like
but let's see what's really going on why
do you need brain scans and bone scans
and yeah 20 20 year prediction
oh this is done
you think it'll be gone there'll be no
more way before that way before that but
what about what about these people
they're home for life
they are literally lifetime medical
patients
when you cut out the womb of a girl
sometimes they cut out just the uterus
sometimes they cut out the ovaries as
well so if this girl gets a little older
she gets to be 25 years of age her
brain's finished developing now she says
what the heck did you do to me i have
all these medical complications she's
gone through menopause yeah you cut out
their ovaries sometimes
that's instant menopause that has 100
side effects of its own early onset
dementia osteoporosis all sorts of
issues a young woman in dc messaged me
two days ago she she was rushed to the
er three times because she's on
testosterone and it was damaging her
kidneys wow
i heard that that causes the blood to
thicken up too
there's so many things and we don't even
know them all you mentioned vision loss
the fda just three or four weeks ago
issued a warning saying that these kids
brains are swelling up and they're
suffering permanent vision loss this is
news a young girl in sweden suffered
spinal fractures while she was on
puberty blockers 12 other kids there
at the karolinska hospital suffered
catastrophic injuries and they've
stopped this in sweden they've stalled
it in finland tavistock
in the uk in england they're shutting
down the tavistock which is the only
gender clinic they are spreading it out
though and making it regional yeah but
they're it's going to be they're going
to totally redo how it's going on and
it's not going to be nearly as extreme
and
i just want to mention one more thing
what never gets talked about enough
at the tavistock where we have good
statistics because there was only one
gender clinic that all the kids went to
in england
35 of the children had moderate to
severe autism that number goes about 50
when you include the mild cases and all
these children's hospitals here in the
us have partnerships with autism
organizations it's like providing a
funnel of kids for them and if you look
at the children's national hospital
website in dc where i was just at
yesterday two days ago
right on their website they have a
gender autism program and it states
right on their website that they don't
yet know why so many autistic kids
experience gender nonconformity
but that doesn't stop them from
sterilizing them why why do you think
they experience gender non-conformity
autistic kids from all the parents i've
spoken to these kids already feel like
they don't fit in
they tend to obsess over things
they're feeling like they don't fit in
and this ideology's coming along and
it's being presented as
the cure for them that it's because
they're trapped in the wrong body which
is why they don't feel like a typical
girl
and that by transitioning this is going
to solve all their problems but all
these kids at these gender clinics have
co-morbidities going on they've got
autism some of them will grow up to be
gay
all of our studies into gender dysphoria
show that 80 to 90 of the time when kids
went through puberty it desisted and the
majority of them were gay the most
recent study that came out followed 139
boys from about the age of five all the
way into their 20s
87.8 percent of them they just grew out
of it 64 grew up to be gay
so in addition to all the other harm
that's going on this is actually a
deeply homophobic movement that's
telling kids just because they don't
conform to stereotypes that this must
mean they're trapped in the wrong body
and my message is one of body positivity
if a girl wants to climb trees play in
the dirt throw around a football hates
wearing dresses and wants to have short
hair guess what she's a hundred percent
girl
it doesn't mean she's a boy
i mean she's that's the weird thing this
uh this movement just reinforces gender
stereotypes it sure does it's all it is
they call it they call it social
constructs but then if someone exhibits
what is clearly as they describe a
social construct they say well i gotta
get surgery and drugs right which
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
now does it no it's not what if the
stereotypes of society change yeah
i mean
people in scotland wear skirts yeah i
mean this dog
what if like some kid from scotland
comes over and they're like is wearing a
skirt oh get the surgery ready so we
already chopped his nuts off sorry
right yikes so these doctors at boston
children's hospital in their own videos
we have this doctor
saying that if a little girl little
toddler girl tries to pee standing up
that's a sign she's a boy
if a little boy doesn't want to get a
haircut that's a sign he's a girl she
literally states in this video that toys
are one of the determining factors
in our gender well and she's not the
only one this is being they're always
doctors all over the place you know if
your child wants to play with drugs and
maybe they're not the gender that you
think they are
and they talk about how kids very young
ages can express that they're in the
wrong bodies before they even know what
a body is necessarily it's also
interesting too that american kids are
prescribed psych drugs like one in 12
american kids
as on a psychiatric medication most of
these have not been fda approved for
kids under 18 as well
you have a lot of kids who are on these
drugs they're on multiple they're on
like major drug cocktails of these
things that are not approved
for kids
and you also have a lot of the kids who
are being prescribed these drugs are
boys who are
uh like lower class boys who have had
multiple child abuse issues as well and
they're being given
masses of um
psych and behavioral drugs it's very
weird what i think
it's very weird what we do to our kids
like and we keep we've been talking
about that a lot tonight i think
between all of the different kinds of
drugs and medications telling them what
we think they are
what we think they're about we're not
educating them properly we're just
trying to indoctrinate that it's so
weird like we don't let kids exist
there's also the inverse
where i i saw these these uh pamphlets
where they're like let your children be
who they are and it's kind of like i
mean you're the parent you got to help
the kid become who they're going to be
right and you have to reinforce them
positively as well so i'll say
it's not a blanket moral logic statement
that indoctrination is bad
indoctrination is a reference to
typically instilling children with
harmful things with values that are
going to do them do them wrong in life
it could be because but well so the idea
is
you could you could technically use a
word in a similar way if you're going to
instill within your child values that
will help them survive and and be happy
and flourish you are instilling values
into them that are good what these
parents are doing is either not
instilling any values letting your kid
be who they are let your child tell you
it's like
i've heard a lot of things from a lot of
kids that don't make sense you know what
i mean
also what happens when that kid tells
you something tells you they are
something that you don't like like a
like a rock like a rock or a cat or i'm
a giraffe or a conservative i am now you
know
last night i was thinking how in times
of war one of the most horrible
byproducts of war is that kids don't get
a childhood they grow up as fast as when
nine-year-olds are carrying around
weapons what does that mean we're in a
childhood like a little eight nine year
old ends up having to be on the front
and fighting or loses their parent and
sees the horror of death when they're
like seven or
they lose their child they're like
forced into the real world without any i
don't i don't like this idea of a
childhood i i really really do well you
want to protect kids throughout the
entire development
throughout the entirety of children
should have jobs the children should
have jobs yes they should they just
should be put in factories
my point is children shouldn't be doing
harmful jobs that will developmentally
stunt them or cause them irreparable
harm but kids should be doing paper
routes kids should be mowing lawns oh
for sure kids should be working the cash
register for the family business kids
should be carrying wood to their dad and
he's prepping the furniture it shouldn't
be seen
and throughout history throughout
history children have been exposed to
the real world and grew up understanding
what the world was throughout history
only throughout the past hundred years
those are bad things and i'm not talking
about that i'm talking about the fact
that over the past hundred years we have
slowly removed children from reality and
now we have an an evolution of snow plow
parenting where kids today think words
themselves are violence because they've
not actually experienced what the real
world is actually like so this idea that
there is such thing as a childhood a
childhood in the 1700s was taking the
musket out back to because you got a
wild hog in the yard and then you were
doing labor with your family to grow
food yeah we developed technology we
made things more comfortable and then we
got wealthier and wealthier as as a
civilization and we took our children
out of reality to shield them from what
we said was too difficult and now we
have whiny snowflakes who want pastel
rooms with bean bags because the man
giving a lecture at their college had a
naughty word you don't expose kids to
sex when they're young you don't expose
them to violence i don't think you
should i think that's what i'm talking
about childhood is you protect kids from
rape you protect kids from
death and maiming and what's happening
is because we're in a global
fifth generational war kids are getting
they're not getting their childhoods
they're getting thrust into this at the
age of seven and now they're they're
turning into you're talking about like
global warfare this is like a
psychological warfare thing that we've
been in for seven years and the kids are
kids and wars in africa who are being
given drugs it's very similar to like
i'm not sure what you're talking like
what are you referencing kids are being
exposed to porn at the age of nine on
average now but that's like in a war
country where like when did you first
see porn oh i was 21. you were 21
yeah i think i saw a video when i was
16. but this is not the same thing ian i
mean what i'm saying is that obviously
in the 1700s there was not going to be a
way for a child to see like five guys in
a donkey and like three women what would
happen is the barbarians would invade
the village and the kid would
either be raped by the attackers or made
to watch like horrible stuff and you
protect kids from that well you try
yeah and it's not working right now
because but
i mean you understand ian that even back
then we prevented those things like we
didn't desperately we would try my point
is that we've created this idea of a
childhood where kids romp around and and
play and do no real work i mean the
craziest thing to me is that in the
united states from the age of zero to
five years old what is a human being
doing literally nothing what do you mean
that's insane they're learning how to do
all kinds of things sure sure like uh uh
give me give me an example you learn how
to tie your shoes and dress yourself you
learn how to wash yourself how long does
it learn how to read yeah you learn kids
you can read at that age you learn how
to you know the average kid is not in
you learn how to collect enough after
yourself yeah but like your parents do
that right like you read no no parents
parents aren't homeschooling their kids
well you don't have to be homeschooling
your kid to teach them how to read and
read to them this is this is bad it's
very bad the the most important years
sweep up the kitchen i mean they just
the most important years of a human
being's life are zero through five and
the next up to thirteen the
developmental years and in the united
states we don't have kids doing anything
i mean sure sure they're gonna tie their
shoes but that's not gonna help them
succeed they do all kinds of things like
my kid was learning how to my kid your
cat's anecdote right yeah you're doing a
good job you know as a parent that's
that's great he learned how to make
averages the average parent is putting
their kid in front of an ipad and
ignoring them and the kids are then
watching insane algorithmic garbage on
on on youtube yeah it was a huge scandal
it's happening way too much and
these kids today
the internet back to the internet this
is the first generation that's grown up
online their friendships are online
these kids who identify as trans are
spending seven hours a day online
that's statistically what's going on
actual sex as teenagers is way down
into the 20s yeah up to 30 years old now
and
you know i don't want to say the word
the g word like james lindsay talks
about this is happening online to these
kids yeah they're getting into these
cultish environments online tick tock
tumbler
anime sites are huge recruiting centers
for this ideology
art that popular website tons of kids
get sucked into it through there even
video games because they're talking to
kids online as they're playing
role-playing games you know they say
missouri loves company
yeah that's what they say
but
we just need to get the truth back out
there because
this is a far left ideology that should
have stayed in some obscure corner of
university where they debated this
ideology for years and now
they're pushing it into all of our
schools it is it is currently prevalent
among the far left but it's not
inherently left-wing you know what i
mean
i don't think so so uh left in terms of
economics or governance hierarchical
structures
the fact that these people believe weird
things about science and biology is
irrespective of how a government should
function or an economy should function
but it's be for whatever reason
critical race theory and gender theory
have been absorbed by the left because
because my my point is you don't see
laissez faire capitalists walking around
demanding an open free market and child
sex changes you know what i mean right
so it is it is currently of the left but
it's not inherent to left political or
economic no not at all and that's the
thing i try to
uh communicate to all the politicians
and everyone when i talk to them
is that this is a hugely winning issue
for anyone to talk about because the
in my experience and i've had about 8
000 conversations on the street more
than 90 of people agree with us of
course we shouldn't be doing this to
kids of course democrats parents
they don't want their kids getting
harmed they don't want them being
sterilized you know look you just you
got to go out and pamphlet for the
republicans saying we would like to ban
child sex changes
and then let people say they agree or
disagree with it well there there is an
issue with that though like i was
talking to
marjorie taylor green about this and she
was saying that republicans are not
coming out
um in favor of banning
gender surgeries for kids
she can't get a whole bunch of people to
join on join in on this i was talking to
somebody about um
why this is happening why more
conservatives aren't jumping on and he
was like oh they can't you know they
can't jump on board because they have to
win their districts and all of this and
it's like just do it just suck it up and
and state the truth that this is
inappropriate and should be stopped
right away this should be the first
thing i ask any politician that comes on
the show and green is right green is
right this stuff should be totally
criminalized yeah at a federal level i
think a lot of them are a lot of them
see this as like the new gay rights
movement and that's what the left wants
you to believe well they want you to do
that because they want to keep getting
money from all of the foundations right
like it wasn't a human human rights
campaign
they were all on board trying to
legalize gay marriage and then as soon
as they got that win they didn't all
want to have to quit their jobs so they
had to pivot to something else it's so
clearly that this is what it is you've
got to keep donating hospitals get a ton
of money for this and because biden just
recently has decided that conversion
therapy
includes telling your kid that they're
not trans right
the next push is to get insurance
companies to cover this for everything
for everything across the board which of
course is actually discriminatory
because if you say that a boy can get
breast augmentation but a woman can't
and the reason is because the boy can
get it because he's a boy and the woman
can't get it because she's already a
woman that's discriminatory on the basis
of sex i say i say you're right 20 years
from now this is all gone but maybe not
for social reasons it's going to be
because we're going to have a lot of
people who are very angry there's going
to be hearings there's going to be
lawsuits there's going to be you know
very serious conflict but also because
these people
you know with without i'm not trying to
be mean to them i think these people are
victims but they're not able to
reproduce
so you've got the left overwhelmingly uh
terminating their own children through
abortion and then many of them are also
sterilizing their own children through
surgeries or through puberty blockers
give it 40 years and this country is
going to be christian conservative
well especially especially if we if we
keep letting in people from south
america
which i don't have really a problem with
so long as it's done legally i mean
trump's winning among latino voters yeah
you know let in the catholics
have a bunch more kids do you want the
country to be christian like a christian
nation or you just think that that's
another that's just what's happening why
do you think that science shows it
happened it already happened in in uh
we've talked about it before in in 2000
there were a couple studies one found
that
conservatives had 2.01 kids and liberals
had like 1.73 or something like that
and that was very simple math if at that
point in 2000
that's how it was breaking down between
conservative families and liberal
families then it was obvious that in 18
years from that point the voters in this
country entering their first voting age
would skew conservative sure enough what
did we see
pew research showed that gen z is the
first generation in 100 years to be
slightly more conservative than the last
now gen z is not as as conservative as
gen x they're just a teeny bit like one
little degree more conservative than
millennials wait gen x is conservative
no they're more conservative than
millennials oh okay gen x is more
conservative than millennials that makes
sense the older you get this is the
classic i think we were more
conservative
millennials gen z is slightly more
conservative than uh gen z is slightly
more conservative than millennials
though they mostly agree on everything
but this is the first time in 100 years
a lot of people thought it was because
there was a breakthrough in culture and
that these kids were based because you
know the right was fighting back and
winning the culture and stuff like that
and it's like no it's because they had
more kids 20 years ago it's that simple
so what are the schools doing now
desperately trying to indoctrinate your
kids because they know they've lost that
fight they know gen z there's more gen z
kids of conservative parents than of
liberal parents and so they're
desperately like we better be able to
get them in the schools but lo and
behold school choice has become a major
issue and they're freaking out over it
because if that happens they've lost
give it two generations give it two
voting cycles and you are going to have
a massive wave of conservative voters in
this country 40 years from now it's
going to be like 51.49 depending on what
happens with immigration there's a whole
bunch of variables at play here but if
we get
two 20-year periods let's say eight 36
years two 18-year periods of
conservatives having tons of kids and
liberals having abortions and
sterilizing their kids the math is very
very simple you will end up with voters
who are just more likely to vote
conservative and the left will start
losing and they'll be desperate to to
bring in some kind of voter to help them
you know what i think i think within one
or two years
we will get
a stop
put to this because there's so much
pressure building and it's going to come
internally from organizations like the
american academy of pediatrics which by
the way we have a big protest planned
for october 8th in anaheim where they're
having their conference there's going to
be 10 000 doctors there
i have doctors messaging me all the time
asking how they can help i have some
going through every research report
that's ever been written so they can
submit things at this conference
but the aap is ignoring calls
already that are happening i think
you've written about it they're ignoring
calls from their own doctors for an
inquiry into this because the average
doctor hates this they just don't know
that it's going on we're talking about a
tiny number of ideological doctors that
are doing this to thousands of kids and
the rest swore an oath
to first do no harm and no matter which
way you slice it there is no
justification for what they're doing to
these kids it's so crazy i can't see how
this lasts for many more years because
the momentum we have is huge and the
last two weeks alone have been massive i
see it on the street i think it really
is simple that if you go to any american
and say would you be in favor of banning
sex changes for children they would say
yeah i think yes absolutely it's all
about framing so what they're doing the
media keeps saying health care for trans
kids and that's not what it means that's
also like how they say allowing trans
kids to play on
to play sports
no no kids who identify as trans are
banned from playing sports anywhere in
the country they are not permitted to
play sports in many places uh on on
teams of the opposite sex that's not
banning you from playing sports at all
not even a little bit
and it's not the whole democratic party
that's in favor of this it's 10 of them
really if it's 10 of them then why is it
i mean it's huge like you had the the
president come out and say affirm your
kid all of the politicians go along with
it why do you think but they're not the
voters right because the media tells
them to they can't stand up to the
radicals in their party they're they're
cowards when the media says well i mean
actually in the past a few primaries the
the far left has been losing and the
moderates had been had been doing fairly
well
uh
so
maybe though maybe that will change but
also with the republican party it's the
inverse the maga republicans are
actually doing way better in the
establishments losing out consistently
and that's why they're going after
that's why they're going after trump
supporters
because those are the people who are
yeah they're losing i'm kind of like i
hope they do i support people's right to
experiment on themselves personally like
if you want to cut yourself if you want
to get a piercing if you want to take a
drug like i'm whatever but when the kid
like a 16 17 year old they're starting
to become an adult but the parents kind
of the guardian like a parent so if a
kid a 12 year old gets gender surgery of
some sort is that not the parent
experimenting on the kid
well i think that parents have different
reasons why they go along with it some
parents i think are just fully
indoctrinated into this mentality
themselves and you would know better
better than me on this some so this is
happening in schools that they're
socially transitioning children changing
their names changing their pronouns and
hiding it from parents
there's a woman in california who names
abigail martinez her story encapsulates
this perfectly her daughter grew up
healthy normal girl they came from el
salvador originally
girly girl wearing princess dresses all
that sort of stuff got into high school
started to hate her body started to get
teased joined the schools qsa or gsa the
queer straight alliance or g k straight
lines club where they feed them pizza
and love bomb them
and tell them that maybe you're born in
the wrong body
and she became indoctrinated to believe
that she was a boy and the school hid
this from her mom why
because her mom is a catholic that
happened in florida as well with a dad
yeah it's happening everywhere uh in
florida january little john who we know
the school drew up a gender transition
plan for her daughter without telling
her right it's crazy but anyway this
girl became indoctrinated to think she
was a boy she was just struggling she
was dealing with depression anxiety
and mom knew that testosterone was not
the best thing for her girl but these
social workers who have known this child
for two or three hours
took her into custody
they took her away from her mom
put her into foster care put her in a
group home with other so-called trans
kids and i do not believe there is such
a thing as a trans kid we should frame
this as children with gender dysphoria
because there's no alternate form of
human there are just girls and boys but
anyway
the state of california took away
custody put her on testosterone and
while she was still separated from her
mom
she knelt down in front of a train
wow
police had to pick her body up in pieces
and this is what's happening in this
country all over the place parental
rights are being stripped away and we
are not allowed to parent our own
children in british columbia where i'm
from a dad went to jail last year
why he spoke out against his daughter's
transition which he was powerless to
stop and you're not even allowed to say
his name in canadian media it's rob
hoogland right i say it all the time
right let them come for me i don't care
well we're not in canada yeah
and so at the age of 13 what happened
was in the delta school district this
girl the first year they taught gender
ideology in school this girl came to
believe she was a boy the school
district sent her to a psychologist
named wallace wong
this guy says he's transitioning over 1
000 kids his youngest patient is two
years nine months old
over 500 of his patients are in the
british columbia foster system wow
that's about 10 of all the kids are they
just sterilizing poor people
the all these kids are struggling these
aren't the kids who are thriving who are
great at sports who are beautiful and
all that these are struggling kids it's
like a new residential school system
yeah whether it's intentional or not
this psychologist sent this girl to the
bc children's hospital and at 13
she signed a consent form for
testosterone the dad wouldn't sign it so
the endocrinologist sent him a letter
which literally states i have it it says
you can be a friend and advisor to your
daughter
but you can't intervene in
essentially her own sterilization
whether it's intentional or not the end
result of this are that poor people are
being sterilized
and medicated and medicated but it will
prevent them from reproducing now if you
went back a hundred years you'd have a
lot of eugenicists cheering for this
right now it's like margaret sanger
would be thoroughly on board with this
whole project eugenics of autistic
children yeah
i can't stress it enough so many of
these kids have autism
where's the autism society they're doing
nothing
you've got a dad from canada traveling
around the world having conversations on
the street getting arrested and
all this crap like where are all the
professional organizations standing up
for these kids it's all parents and
beautiful wonderful people like libby
evans who's doing more of any journalist
in the entire world to expose this the
amount of content you put out is
incredible so i love you to death
but this is such a problem and we've
gotta all speak up about it more because
it's not about hate it's the exact
opposite it's love and we're the ones
trying to help these kids to be who they
really are it's true too but i will also
say that i think it's inevitable that
this stuff ends because these people are
clearly we're already seeing on the d
trans subreddit 40 000 people and
regular posts about how their lives are
ruined from this yeah so you can't just
stop people from speaking and it's
already going to a dark place because
it's been going on for a while now so i
feel like it's inevitable that sooner or
later there's going to be too many
people who are there's going to be
lawsuits there's going to be committee
hearings
there's going to be there's going to be
people in medical doesn't mean doctors
probably go to jail
you know i don't know how many but i
think when you get enough people
there's going to be hearings there's
going to be fines going to be penalties
we can look back at some of the medical
practices we've had in this country
thalidomide being you know example of
a big mistake mm-hmm yeah that was
basically
people were affected by it
and there's going to be hearings and
there's going to be recompense of some
sort the man who invented the lobotomy
won the nobel prize for medicine oh good
for him i mean they suck ice picks
through people's orbital sockets
i swear through orbital sockets
seriously yes through the top of the
eyeballs they they're just ice picks
essentially that's all they are and they
just jabbed away at the prefrontal
cortex
and zombified people well a couple
people seem to get better
so this must be great
yeah wasn't there like a a kennedy or
somebody who got that or something like
that i was reading that on reddit i
think there was also all of the
electroshock therapies remember that
that was like considered to be helpful
for people i know someone who went
through that and eventually she died of
alcoholism actually i read i read an
article that if you do a really low
level current through your brain it like
increases your cognitive faculties or
something i've done that let's all do
that yeah i was reading something like
that no
this guy did a thing where it was like a
seriously low current you know on his
temples or whatever oh yeah and then
they did tests and he performed better
at math or something i had those um
those those like electro massage things
where you like put them on your muscles
and they slowly turn up the thing
when i had physical therapy put it on my
temples never again one time i was like
oh that's too much current not there but
uh i had that with physically it was
like a normal guy wearing a suit and he
was like what an interesting product
yeah they saw those ab cruncher things
like put the belt on and it like
exercises for you
the weirdest thing is videos but
but hold on i'm confused by this because
you can just choose to crunch your abs i
don't you know i never do that yourself
it doesn't work
the the the the belt or whatever it's
called the spasm but it's not going to
make them yeah right right but but my
thought on this was like you can buy a
product to do what you can literally do
by thinking
it's like it's almost telecase you can
be like i'll crunch my abs while i sit
here you can just do it you don't need
to buy a thing to do it i don't get it
human wants it done for them even if you
can just think it right now that is
laziness i don't want to think it's
amazing just do it for you i don't want
to think well i guess you can go to bed
you'd sleep well then you just go to
american schools you know it's so dumb
too because ab exercises don't give you
a six-pack
dehydration and losing weight gives you
a six-pack that's right dehydration yes
so that's why you look at because when
you unless your diet is perfect yeah no
no not even like you see these photos of
you know chris hemsworth or whatever in
the movies and he's like all ripped and
chiseled and then you see him on the
beach and he looks like oh he looks a
little thick what's up with that and
it's like that's what human beings look
like when you're hydrated so what they
do for these photo shoots in these
movies is they don't drink water for a
day oh you're just kidding oh yeah yeah
and then the skin dries out and you look
thin and then you can see the muscles i
drink so much water but they're they're
i'm not that's not true of everybody
drinking water there are people with six
packs it's just very low body i'm not
one of them i just drink a lot of water
anyway one of my best buddies is big
into fitness i've been to the olympia a
few times too and we pick up some of
these bodybuilders and stuff from the
airport and they're all angry because
they haven't eaten and they're
dehydrating themselves yeah so then
you're ready with a rice cake and some
egg whites for them because they're
getting ready for competition they've
lost 30 pounds in the last month
all right all right we're going to jump
over to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member of that
members only show coming up at about 11
p.m you don't want to miss it and of
course my friends
if you would like
to help me lure people in to my right
wing world you can click the link in the
description below and purchase only ever
wanted our latest song from teamcast
records our first song where uh the plan
right now is to release a song probably
every four or five weeks we've got a
bunch lined up already i'm constantly
writing more and we've got other artists
in the house obviously ian writes carter
writes and we're actually planning on
bringing more artists in as well so
there will be a consistent stream of new
new music coming out
so uh with your support um we will be
able to exponentially increase the rate
at which we pull people into our right
wing world i mean that's what the daily
beast said so appreciate your support
all right now let me try and pull up
these super chats because youtube
has been uh it's the chat causing the
browser to crash i guess
which is unfortunate
we got too many super chats
tonight yeah we got two money too many
super chats oh it's the last day of
august too huh yeah
wow
a lot of super chats okay this is a this
is a crazy amount of super chats by the
way people can go to billboardchris.com
if they need to contact okay
okay let's see here we'll grab uh some
super chats real quick
uh where were we ah yes
ready to rumble says kim iverson matt
walsh twitter war is something happening
between kim iverson and matt welsh that
i didn't see i only saw that kim was
pointing out that the age of consent is
indifferent different in different
states which is that that's true but i
don't know if she's flaming with matt
interesting
all right waffle sensei says tim your
butt rock is a gateway to dark maga
nuclear ultra dark manga
the worst
waffles then says tim next tim cast
single will be called butt rock no
actually we were planning on doing a gag
called is this what you want and writing
a dance pop song oh nice yeah and
because we were like all these lefties
were like this music is dated it sounds
like the 2000s or whatever and i'm like
you mean when there was good music but
no but kate bush is number number five
on the billboard hot 100 that's 80s and
it's been a hot song for you who doesn't
like the 90s were you kidding me like
great music in the 2000s but anyway i'm
like so what people write music for the
music they they write music that's what
happens it doesn't matter what year it
was people are doing retro stuff plus
it's not like any good music is coming
out now but that's not even that's not
even the issue it's like
we we ended up looking at the how 100
and we were like is this the kind of
music we should be making and so we like
grabbed a bunch of random songs and
listened and it's like
dance boppy simplistic and we were like
okay so we'll make a song called is this
what you want and it'll be about going
to the club with some girl that's nice
that's it that's it and it'll it'll be
hilarious and it'll be like you know ian
you know dancing at the club
no we're not giving the melody out we
can't we can't give it away it's gonna
be really good yeah and we're going to
we're going to need i don't want to give
it away yeah stop giving
you're giving it up ian come on i'm a
magician we're going to make a million
dollars off this song it's going to be
because this is what they want this is
what they want
to find out i mean they want us to make
a question you know a remake of tiny
dancer i got an idea here's what we do
okay tiny dancer right now
this is this is the number one song on
itunes it's hold me closer by britney
spears and elton john so they took an
old classic from the 70s made it a dance
song i got it all we got to do is make a
dance pop version of a good 70s hit
how about fortunate sun that was the 70s
right or was it was that late 60s i'm so
into that yeah that'll be dead dance pop
credence clearwater revival fortunately
john fogerty is that his name yeah
singer yeah let's do uh dance pop one by
three dog night nice let's go back even
further let's do rag mop dance pop do
you guys know rag mob just get some
betty goodman out there
it's our face it's one guy's face and
then it like blends into the other guy's
face as we're all singing the lyrics and
then into the other guy's face you know
what is fun though
all the old motown stuff with the guys
doing the like this yeah dance we got to
bring back a dance night that's great
stuff the choreography yeah like gladys
knight in the pips vino says if you play
tim's song backwards it's trump's
campaign propaganda did you all notice
that the song actually is the
instrumentation is backwards
maybe you should play it backwards and
see what you hear it forwards and hear
it forwards
it's like you are hearing a song by tim
poole the song now continues that's all
you hear
sean l says youtube now adds context to
videos about abortion the definition is
so broad it would apply to c-sections
how do people not see this is happening
in real time
yo i don't know it just it feels like
we're being they treat us like we're
chickens in a chicken coop you know but
like just a little bit smarter than
chickens are they filming us just like
your chickens
i mean what if they were what's the
truth we don't even know it right that's
the funny thing
chicken city is the chicken truman show
yeah i was thinking about that they
don't mind they're all walking around
doing chicken stuff like normal life
going
and there's like cameras watching
everything they do right they don't even
know one of them's gonna find out i
think the reason people aren't seeing it
happen in real time that would be a
great animated information okay but that
would be a killer animation like one
chicken chicken
one of the chicken finds out finds out
that he's actually on chicken city cat
are you listening it's a really that
would be really funny all right logan
culver says speaking of mtg just want to
shout out the best gaming store on the
east coast the white knights game room
in williamsport pa has to be the largest
inventory and gaming area oh very nice
yeah we did for the cast castle up on
cass castle youtube channel marjorie
taylor green turns out she's a pro tier
magic the gathering player who'd have
thought that mtg played mtg yeah
it was funny it was funny
is that out yet all right mark it is it
is yeah
mark va says actually tim from your
previous video it's two-thirds of the
senate is needed to convict and remove a
president or other defined officer
article 1 section 3 thanks for all your
content ah yes i said 60. it is it is
what 67.
so more than that more than that
charles neil says i've been a
correctional officer for the last eight
years i recently started a non-profit
called humane justice foundation a
foundation made up of officers and
former inmates would love to come on
well we will uh we'll take a look into
it my friend thanks for the super chat
ian kinney says someone shouted out
chris webby last night yes check out raw
thoughts 4 and five also topher the
marine rapper struggle jennings tommy
vext and burden culture vultures very
cool man gotta gotta win the culture
stuff i think fake woke by tom mcdonald
reached number 14 on the itunes top 100.
nice because i was you know i was
shouting it out saying that people gotta
buy music to support the culture and
then tom tweeted about it he's like i'm
number three in rap i don't know where
he's at now but he's number 14 on the on
top 100.
so that's cool right yeah
let's grab uh uh-oh
murph tri says libby you can never trust
a hot chick it might be james o'keefe in
disguise this is this is what worries me
y'all this is a concern
yeah he's gonna pull off the
mask and suddenly it's going to be
it's going to be like those mission
impossible masks and there's going to be
like a hot chick and then it's going to
when it's ok pull off the arms too yeah
yeah he grows several feet
we had a vancouver person in the
comments there yes which one that's cool
uh they'd seen me at many of the
anti-band date protests this one nice oh
vyrick says holy ish i've seen this guy
while doing multiple anti-mandate
protests in vancouver we had so many
marches with thousands of people that
the news just didn't cover yeah you know
kovit was annoying to me because i was
out there having conversations about
this and all the conservative media were
always focused on code which i
understand of course but i knew that
once coveted finally waned that
conservatives would finally get on board
with this and it's happening so i'm
excited get on board with with talking
about gender ideology what's happening
to kids you know all right valoren says
shout out to james o'keefe for his work
on getting results and freeing the
schools from the fascists who don't hire
catholics next up the fbi yeah good job
james o'keefe that guy's put on leave
now he admitted to committing crimes
so how do you get criminals out if you
don't have people like james o'keefe
this is why they hate him so much i was
talking to a guy
and uh i mentioned
somehow james o'keefe came up and he was
like i don't know that james o'keefe guy
man nah he's not good and i was like
what why and he was like because he just
puts out fake stuff all day and i was
like no he doesn't there's one did when
did he ever do that
well i don't know i saw i watch what
they say about him and i'm like bro you
are wrong about all of it uh you know
right now we have a video it's one guy
one assistant principal at one school
admitting to committing serious crimes
on an ongoing basis discriminatory
crimes
and we only found out because james
o'keefe has this operation right and he
went and dealt with it this is like what
happened with libs of tick tock you know
she was putting out all of this
information about what was going on at
gender clinics and reporters at the
washington post and npr and nbc instead
of taking you know the material that she
put out and saying like oh i wonder
what's going on here let me actually try
to do some digging instead of doing that
they blasted her and demanded that
twitter
ban her account
they don't want to look into it they
just want to blast the journalists who
are
actually doing the the work and the
reporting
all right restless medic says chris what
in your opinion can be done to prevent
canadian politicians from catering to
people in toronto and montreal at the
expense of everyone west of manitoba
common complaint of my fiance's family
in victoria
these politicians and canada men
vote them all out
that's the only answer
that we don't have one
single brave politician who will stand
up and tell the truth about any of this
why do you think that is it because it's
the queen you'll just kick him out what
why no nothing to do with that these
man
they passed unanimously a lot it made it
a crime
to help a girl feel comfortable as a
girl punishable by two years in prison
and a five million dollar
five years in prison and a two million
dollar fine unanimously voted for this
we have one politician who will tell the
truth about all this culture war stuff
his name is maxine bernier he almost won
the leadership of the conservative party
he missed out by one percent and he was
so disgusted with them all that he went
and formed his own party called the
people's party of canada
so
they secured about 800 000 votes last
election five percent of the vote
but all these conservatives are cowards
man i'm calling them out all the time
i've gone to some of their events i've
been escorted out
because
i'm there to hold these people
accountable and get answers to these
important questions about child abuse
and they won't address it
crazy so we just need to vote them all
out yep
trying 54 says tim your source is
correct
t-s-i-s-c-i cover letters are controlled
in the same manner as their contents the
fbi just committed an intentional and
intentional uncontrolled spillage onto
social media confirm with poso or that
would imply they are declassified
simply put right
the fbi wouldn't intentionally publish
classified materials unless trump
declassified them in which case it is
one big hoax
it's a hoax
neglectful sausage says imagine you're
upset living under totalitarian rule uh
under trudeau having no freedom losing
your voice and doing nothing about it
yep i'm really concerned man i i i have
so much love for canadian people in
general and like i want i don't know do
you think that the that we could unify
the states of across canada and the
united states to create kind of a
greater federation
well i think we need to get rid of
california and some places like that and
then we can form a new country sure the
value of california is all the ocean
access yeah
you know what most of california is
great it's just the cities you know
cities in general you get 50 yeah
totally you get 50 miles outside of los
angeles and you might as well be in
kentucky it's amazing
it's so nice out there i love california
especially northern california all right
dapper mcstache says hey tim you've said
a president has declassification power
but i can't find proof former presidents
do too do you know a source or evidence
of that because i can't find one thanks
y'all are great i do not believe former
presidents have that the point is that
donald trump declassified them when he
decided to take them when he was still
president that's the point
but i i i don't know do former
presidents have declassification power
probably not unless it pertains to
if it were it would have to pertain to
their specific role i would imagine but
i'd assume they wouldn't the issue is
donald trump said he tweeted out i'm
declassifying all these documents
related to crossfire hurricane
simply upon taking them declassified so
i don't know
interesting to say the least
waffle sensei says ian to be honest
hillary clinton the 529 insurrectionist
and everybody else you name has been
effectively pardoned i don't see the
purpose in pardoning people that were
never held accountable
i think that the pardon is a sort of i
mean maybe it's not a sort of holding
them to account but like
it's kind of acknowledgement that wrong
was done
i you know that's i'm looking for that
bobcat says tim when are you going to
record some of these songs you were
playing with adam on jam nights we've
been waiting for a proper recording of
them for over a year i think that was i
think only ever wanted was one of the
songs i played maybe not i don't know um
we've got
i think three that are that are one is
completely done has been done since like
what april
yeah yeah and we've just like been
planning how to release it because we
were planning on doing an album and then
decided that it's not really the way
things work anymore you know putting
like dropping an album just muddies
things up
so we've got one song that we're
probably ready to release in four weeks
we're working on a lyric video for it
but we'll see we'll see we're working
with some industry guys to figure out
the best way to get it radio play and
and properly launch it
we we properly launched to a certain
degree only ever wanted but we missed a
ton of things like
you know there's a lot of uh business
and stuff we don't know so we got it on
all these platforms but there's a lot of
things we did miss
so hopefully the next release in about
four or five weeks will be even better
it'll be a lot of fun i wish we could do
music videos for every single one but
lyric videos are probably what we're
gonna get
all right
jesus chris says congrats tim on being
the face of the church church of woke's
version of the satanic panic of the 80s
and 90s shame on your rock music nah
it's all fake news we released a song
two years ago called will of the people
and a lot of people are saying they like
that one better because that one's like
overtly political but they didn't come
out and say this
anything about me when we launched that
song they did not care i think the issue
is
will of the people was a political
message
and it did well among people who are
into politics this song is apparently
doing well among regular people who
aren't involved and that's the scariest
thing to the woke beast that we could
actually build cultural influence with
people who are not involved in politics
and then instead of coming out like
natalie portman and being like defund
the police we'll come out and be like
nah
no we're not going to do that that's
dumb you know what i want to say too
it's like
these satanic panic people
it's like they're they're just not cool
you know what i mean they're like the
dorky kids who are like it's so lame
that they're making music it's like okay
dude well they don't care exactly i'm
having fun all these people who want to
defund the police are the first ones to
call the police on me when i show up
somewhere yeah yeah every time
all right joe spinella says common-law
marriage both parties sign a mutual
contract devoid of lawyers
yeah
i don't know i thought common law was
like you just magically become married
after seven years or something i thought
that was what it was too
yeah i don't really know garnet says
chris the sixth leading cause of death
in canada is euthanasia being poor is a
reason for euthanasia and canada
ca va is advising soldiers with ptsd to
euthanize themselves now prairie pro
prov joined the u.s now yeah that's
correct a vet called in
called veteran services to get help with
some issues that he was having and he
was recommended euthanasia i'm telling
you it really does sound like they're
just trying to reduce population they
passed a bill last year euthanasia and
now it's the sixth leading cause so a
guy so a guy
you can also have medical conditions be
a reason why you're seeking
suicide which obviously like you have a
medical condition
well i mean a mental mental condition oh
mentally i was going to say medically
like yeah if you've got like stage four
cancer that's inoperable or incurable
you know it's a different question but
but they're talking about mental illness
as a reason to seek suicide which it
used to be that we would try to prevent
people with mental health
you call an emergency hotline and you're
like i'm feeling really bad man i need
help have you thought about killing
yourself have you thought about
taking these extra drugs and dying right
now oh my god no i don't want to do that
i need help to stop me from doing that
and they're like
well here in canada
you know suicide would be paid for yeah
the forbes author who quote writes about
accessibility inclusion and social
justice wrote quote canada's you new
youth and asia laws carry upsetting
nazi-era echoes warren experts i think
they're right yeah it's not good it's
horrifying no one's talking about it
they also put out workbooks for kids so
that kids can better understand the
process of uh government-funded suicide
i'm i'm gonna read this but preface by
saying it is incorrect mtg says ian is
the prime example of the
college-educated newman who knows
nothing of money but doesn't pay his
loans and waits for us to do so glad i
dropped out worked hard and honest and
stayed debt-free now i get to pay his
but i just want to pause and say that
ian has adamantly stated several times
he doesn't want that to happen no i'm
not going to take the any kind of loan
repayment if it's a tax burden uh i'd be
down for taking 580 billion off of
sallie mae's books if you guys want to
do that
make them pay it at least invest like
look into doing that and see what that
would be but to print 580 billion and
give it to sally may no i'm not taking
part well they already printed it that's
disgusting it was printed when the loan
was issued and now by not paying it back
it's just you got free stuff i don't see
how joe biden or any one person should
have that authority to be able to do he
doesn't either
nancy pelosi said that joe biden doesn't
have the power to do this and now
they're like yay and it doesn't i'm not
happy
yeah all of these universities have
massive endowments they should be the
ones paying it back
i talked about this with someone the
other day
the
in their articles of incorporation or
whatever
there's specific ways they're allowed to
spend that money and they're legally
prohibited from doing that yeah it's too
bad okay okay this one's a good one
liquid eight two five says love you ian
are you from this planet
i don't know i still don't know
i think at some point the tide pool was
splashed by fungus so that you're
actually one of those you're like a squi
you're wherever the squids came from
yeah
you gotta watch the cass castle video
with marjory taylor green and ian
because it's really good dude we shot
more today uh it's really good thanks
things are shaping up we're really fun
we've got like it's a it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a three or four part arc
a four-part you know it's gonna be like
an hour an hour and a half long the next
cast castle is going to be an epic
but i can't say anything because the
first episode's going to hit like a
hammer
it's going to be so good so yeah i don't
want to talk about i want to not like
that's next tuesday right yeah every
tuesday next tuesdays is going to be
really good nice really good that's
exciting yeah i don't think youtube
would you know
the jokes we're going for here yeah you
guys are going to love it it's going to
be so good we got so much to it might be
four parts we'll see
dws says finally listen to will of the
people then i listen to the one the the
one muse made tim's song hey be careful
the violent revolutions it begets more
violent revolutions muse let's have a
violent revolution bro
i was thinking about that
will of the people that i wrote is a
song that shows a cycle of statues being
rotated every time they get pulled down
and it's how everybody thinks they're
fighting for the will of the people but
they're all just fighting for their own
personal gain in power or vendettas and
then mews made a song called will of the
people where it's just people tearing
down statues and destroying cameras and
stuff like yay revolution
and i have to wonder
if the if the impact of will of the
people from me was to encourage people
to not engage in revolution muse then
buries my content by screaming no no no
i have the revolution and it makes me it
makes me wonder you know it makes me
wonder about about muse
well it's i think it's very strange that
if you go to youtube music and search
for tim cast muse will of the people is
the first result yeah because that
doesn't seem like it's an accident
because that search term has nothing to
do with music i watched a live muse
video of them like doing a live singing
of us one of the they're they're
talented really really talented
musicians but that was kind of an empty
um an empty song that will the people
that marilyn manson cover basically you
know what yeah the beautiful people the
beautiful people twitchy spaz says tim i
think this needs to be said hormone
therapy is legit helpful people are born
with hormone imbalances and the medicine
helps when applied right that i
understand absolutely what we're talking
about here but right we're not talking
about that for sure
trt for life says all testosterone taken
by adults is synthetic kids are getting
the same that i take for trt please get
educated on this issue
uh-huh yeah we should have a
testosterone
yeah yeah i think that's what we
literally said we said it was something
that's a good we should have more
doctors on the show to talk about this
stuff right now oh i don't know youtube
would ban us yeah i wonder if we could
have it i can get you doctors if you
want doctors they've got a new election
policy that says you can't share hacked
materials and i'm like how am i supposed
to know if the new york post publishes a
story and i'm like oh i'm going to read
this i'll get in trouble for it you
think i'm psychic youtube you morons
the canadian government froze bank
accounts based on hacked materials
people who donated to the trucker convoy
yeah
and how did they get that list
it was hacked and released by whatever
journalist and then they acted on it to
freeze bank accounts of people who
donated a hundred dollars to a peaceful
protest if at the top of the alphabet
chain the company that owns google that
owns youtube if they're
the government the american government's
like censor this stuff or we're shutting
you down in the united states we already
know that's true like they're up against
getting shut down in the united states
we've already had what's going on tom
fitton uh report on democrats going to
uh silicon valley
telling them like this has to be removed
we already have alex berenson saying
that the government went to twitter and
said why hasn't he been banned yet we
know it's happening the fbi went to mark
zuckerberg and they said hey there's
going to be you know some uh information
coming out you might want to bar or
something like that and then right
around the time they were supposedly
trying to not interfere over the hunter
biden laptop investigation by not
investigating it right and then they
just so happened to go to mark
zuckerberg at the time how convenient
for them yeah we know they're doing it
waffle sensei says see this is why we
need men and women tim says kids don't
need a childhood like a strong beefy
warrior man a mother is needed to
cultivate a child's imagination so they
can carry humanity forward i did not say
that a mother is not needed for that and
my point was that our idea of childhood
has become so insane that kids now think
words are violence
a childhood used to be a kid mowed the
lawn and did chores and worked
and then when you come out you're like
kids should have jobs they go how dare
you and it's like you never shoveled
snow you never shovel the sidewalk you
know i worked at my family business i
put money in a cash register and took
money out it was not the end of the
world it was teaching a kid
responsibility and they like doing it i
like doing it yeah it's fun mikey
recently when he could have a job
and i was like i'll put you to work
right now yeah absolutely
and then my parents would create a chore
list pam yeah they would put a chore
list on the refrigerator saying like
dishes lawn laundry or whatever and then
you know market rate for the uh for the
task and then you'd be like okay i'll go
do it then you'd do it and then you'd do
the job again could you outbid your
brother and be like i'll do it for that
never 18 less that i don't that may have
happened one time i'm not sure but i
don't think so we used to go
door-to-door i don't know if kids still
do this we'd go door-to-door and be like
do you need your lawn mowed do you need
your snow shoveled or whatever and
they'd be like sure and then we'd be
like 10 bucks and i was always just like
i'm going to ask for more and then i'd
be like 20 bucks and they gotta be like
20 bucks and then i'd be like well what
would you give me is that give me 15.
i'm like yes
that's still better yeah man the art of
the deal you know negotiate the terms
you shovel snow
and then kids got to do work to earn
stuff i'm not saying put them in the in
the mines or anything like that that's
bad yeah when i'm saying protect a kid's
childhood i'm not in any way saying
don't make them get a job i got a job
when i was 12 and i'm glad
yeah they don't need to read books with
child porn in grade six protect their
minds
i do think that there's a lot of things
kids should do around the home without
getting paid because they got to pull
their own weight correct
like my son has to deal with the laundry
and the dishes and all kinds of other
stuff and he doesn't get paid for that
what i was going to pay him to do was
honestly i'm going to be driving
tomorrow when biden is doing the his
speech so i'm going to be listening to
the speech and i'm going to pay my kid
to uh take notes for me and be like nice
write this down write that down oh is
that the statement tomorrow no it's not
the state of the union it's where he's
going to call us all fascists and claim
that we have no souls
all right psychodragon says fun fact
ronald reagan was the first governor to
sign no fault divorce into law other
states soon followed but you can thank
marilyn monroe you ask yourself why the
60s and 70s history isn't discussed yeah
reagan also pushed gun control i love
how they really like reagan for some
reason reagan pushed gun control because
of the um yeah because of the black
panthers in in oakland who were out
there when
uh police would pull black people over
and they'd see the black panther
standing there with guns and the black
panthers would be like um what are you
gonna do now good yeah it's called the
second amendment baby for real and
that's why reagan started dealing with
gun control because he didn't want black
people in in oakland to have guns this
is why when i saw it it's not a good
thing yeah
when i saw antifa standing out with
those guns outside of that drag shot i
was like good
good for them were those actual guns
yeah look pretty actually
okay you're allowed to do it now the
show going on inside i have you know
issues with for sure
but uh the right to keep in bear arms
now i do think that's new for antifa
because they've traditionally been
against guns no no no no no no no
always been pro
yeah john brown socialist rifle
association john brown gun club they are
pro-gun as they come baby okay
wrong yeah they there was even one
antifa guy john brown gun club had a
ghost gun and went and started shooting
at an ice facility in the fire bomb
canadian antifa maybe because canadians
are opposed you can't even have a gun
well no and trudeau has just banned
purchase transfer or import of all guns
exactly and they've they're introducing
a new one we know where this goes yeah
we're going to be sitting in america
just like watching the news about the
canadians being shuffled into uh you
know medical centers or something i
would hope for euthanasia people would
not stand for recommended recommended
euthanasia and sterilization at what
point do they it stops being an option
it starts being mandatory for certain
ailments
i mean it is socialized medicine so at
what point are you going to say
well they're going to say look you've
got you know stage 3 cancer so you're
being prescribed euthanasia
that's the concern that we had in the
u.s remember when people were talking
about the aca and there were concerns
over like death panels you know yeah
well we know how people are treating
these long-term care homes too yeah no
not particularly collected yeah yeah
especially last night right lost cause
says tim it wasn't the fact that they
were offering the person to off themself
they said they did it before and uh did
it before and even got counseling for
the person's kids also the person still
works for the hotline
all right what super chats do we have
here
what's a diagon
ronnie says ken in the us should make
diagolon look it up
that sounds like it's something bad that
sounds terrible trying to trick me into
reading bad things it's like a disease
hoban says hi tim i want to correct the
record school choice would not stop woke
schools and could even make it worse
because less oversight if you'd like to
know more james lindsay talks a lot
about this ah interesting interesting
yeah james lindsay's not totally in
favor of the school choice that's for
sure
well i am i don't get that my friends if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
we have a members only show coming up
for you at about 11 p.m and if you would
like to once again help us lure people
into a right wing world using the power
of rock
then click the link in the description
below and buy our song only ever wanted
because we greatly appreciate it we are
going to be pushing it just until
tomorrow tomorrow's the last day because
that's just how that's when they do song
tracking i don't know if the song will
actually chart or anything like that we
did get a lot of play but
i don't think we're on like radios or
anything like that so but purchases
purchases matter it's 150 streams
uh for every one purchase and so if we
got like 10 you know tens of thousand
then it would we would probably chart or
something like that and uh we just want
to have an impact and we won't have a
good launch for the music endeavors
we're doing because we're going to do a
bunch more and i really do appreciate
all of your support you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast billboard chris you want to
shout anything out
i just really appreciate being here if
people want to reach out to me they can
find me on billboardchris.com
and i'm on twitter at billboardchris now
they're censoring me my account is
deemed adult content so you have to
enter a birthdate 18 plus to follow me
what on twitter yep weird and you i
don't show up in the search bar either
but on my website you'll find me
and uh yeah people want to support me
there's a donate button there too but
really i just ask people to have
conversations about this because that's
how we're going to defeat this one
conversation at a time
what about you libby hey guys i'm
searching for billboard chris yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
is it billboard chris yeah when you type
it you can click on the app billboard
chris and then you'll find me but i
don't show up in the search
i'm
results
evans i you can find me at libbyemen's
on twitter
or
at thepostmillennial.com
and we've got a lot of great com content
up also at humanevents.com so come say
hi yes and you can follow me at ian
crossland anywhere on the internet uh i
would love one final time for today
point you towards the new cast castle
vlog
it's on uh youtube
i don't know if it's cat search cascast
on youtube if you want to see a clip but
if you go to timcast.com find cass
castle on the left you can watch the
full episode just released yesterday
uh and there's more to come the next
week next next week i think is going to
be the most ridiculous and funny stuff
we've ever done and we've got
one bit that i know youtube would
probably ban us over
so it's like that's exciting yeah well
we're going to keep it a secret because
people you know who want to watch the
show will enjoy it and it's on the
subscriber side yep nice but we put the
so what we're doing is
once a week what we're aiming to do is
every wednesday have our cameos from our
guests doing something funny so we had
marjorie taylor green playing match at
the gathering uh who did we have before
the was the jackpot delivering the
scripts for tim kessler that's really
cute that was funny yeah and then we've
got one planned next week which is going
to be uh really funny today obviously we
had ian and marjorie taylor green so
we're going to keep having you know
people cameo and do funny bits but then
the full show itself is on timkes.com
gotcha i can read from trudeau's new
action plan for the 2s lgbtq
hilarious yeah that'll play well yeah
yeah that's great thank you very much
for coming chris thank you for joining
us once again libby always a good time
chris your story is awesome i'm really
looking forward to this bonus segment
you guys can all follow me on twitter
and mines.com at sourpatchlids as well
as sourpatchlids.me we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about an hour
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you